we want to get started
um before we start if I could ask
representative McKenzie to lead us in
the Pledge of Allegiance
uh representative avalani is going to
fill in for the clerk momentarily so if
you could take role for the committee
please
oh certainly Mr chairman uh I am present
representative proud
representative love
it's representative Boyd
representative Mason here
representative column
representative Drago
here
representative Granger here
representative Sullivan
representative Rudy here
representative Cahill yeah
representative D Silvestro
representative Susie
representative Bouchard here
representative attitude
representative McKenzie here
representative Schultz
representative Leclair here
thank you and the chair
here
we have a quorum Mr chairman
thank you very much
um at this point I'd like to open the
hearing on HB 241
and ask the prime sponsor representative
Sheehan to introduce the bill
good morning thank you
I'm representative Vanessa Sheehan and I
represent Hillsboro District 43 the town
of Milford
in comments I received from my school
board members I discovered that they
were being forced to lose time from
their day-to-day work obligations due to
negotiations for Union contracts
as we all realize school board members
are in a thankless community service
position but they should not have to
lose substantial pay or vacation time
just to fulfill the school board duties
specifically negotiations
the new language shown in this bill
simply defines reasonable opportunity to
mean prior to 9 A.M or after 6 PM so it
would be possible for a school board
member to satisfy both their elected
School Board position as well as their
work obligations
police also note that the language of
this bill is specifically written for
school districts as I'm unaware of any
scheduling issues to be concentrated
with the school Union negotiations in
other areas I'm not wishing to affect
negotiations with other bargaining units
such as Municipal Police or fire unions
and I'm willing to take any other
questions you have thank you for your
testimony I do have a question are you
aware in the existing contract
the terms that talk about who represents
the union and at to what extent they can
do that on
work hours on on school time
do you know if that's covered in the
existing contract
um no I don't I just know that it's been
very difficult for them to settle on a
time other than in the middle of the day
all right thank you another question is
um
do you know if this has gone to the
pelrb for resolution no I do not okay
thank you
other questions for the prime sponsor
I see none so thank you very much thank
you very much
and I see that the clerk has arrived
not a problem uh
you want to take over
yes I I shifted into Will's chair
before he left the coffee
I came asleep
are you do you want uh
representative I wanted to continue for
the next speaker well you get
um okay
so next I would like to call a
co-sponsor representative king
um
in support of the bill and he has
written testimony
good morning Mr
and thank you for allowing me to speak
this morning
and I'd also like to thank the The
Honorable committee members of the labor
industrial and Rehabilitation committee
for the record I am representative Bill
King I represent Hillsboro District
number 43.
as
um
representative Sheehan has already
mentioned a lot I will be brief and I
know there's others behind me that have
more information
but um as far as why I support this bill
HP 241 is a bill designed to accommodate
the school board members attending
bargaining units who work a daytime job
as well
many times these meetings are scheduled
during the middle of the day when many
representatives like School Board meet
members cannot take time off
from their work obligations without
losing their money monetary obligation
opportunities
asking for these meetings to be
scheduled before 9 A.M or after 6 PM is
a small ask
please support ought to pass on HB 241
I'll take questions although I'm
not you've already thrown on a couple
dandies so thank you I assume you you
don't know the answers of the ones you
answer you asked no okay thank you other
questions for this Witness
I I don't know if you or maybe somebody
else is testifying in those but who
actually schedules the meetings
I'm assuming that comes from and
actually I'll let um I think uh Nate
wheeler will be talking to this and he
could probably tell you because he's the
one that gets the schedule
okay thank you
other questions
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
and uh with that and introduction I
would like to call Nate wheeler who will
be speaking in support of the bill
foreign
thank you chair and honorable board for
letting me speak my name is Nate wheeler
I am a the vice chair of the Milford
school board here today to speak on my
own behalf in relation to this bill and
my experiences in negotiating
this past year
um you know as a voluntary School Board
member it's quite hard to balance both
life and uh your duties as a elected
official as I'm sure most of you are
aware it becomes even harder when you're
mandated to have a meeting during the
middle of your work day uh to to
complete negotiations
my experiences is that the lawyers
representing both sides
will come in and just tell you when
they're available and
um you just kind of have to deal with
that there is no
um back and forth really it's hey I have
these times available I have these times
available and you just kind of have to
stick with it well this past year trying
to negotiate
um in good faith in allowing
um the unions to negotiate during work
hours where their pay is protected and
my pay is not
um we we were forced into meeting at one
in the afternoon well for a general
contractor when I'm working in Bosco and
I have to drive back to Milford you just
canceled my entire day's work you just
took it right off the table from me
um so we made good faith options to try
and meet
um in the morning during their work
schedule and in the afternoon during
their work schedule
um both of which they they just insisted
that we have several meetings during the
middle of the day so that's that's not
good faith from one side to the other
making people lose work when their pay
is protected
furthermore it takes teachers out of
their obligation to teach and educate
and it takes them out of ongoing
education when they negotiate on days
that should be a teacher Workshop day
that takes them out of that ongoing
education for their own career so it
takes away from students this this bill
fixed by law is much better than going
before the labor board because quite
frankly right now it's not supported in
law the law says that the labor board
would
um
oh the labor board wouldn't uphold this
as Fair Labor practice at the moment
because the law says they don't have to
so we need to fix this in law and make
it fair for all parties involved this
bill also still allows you with written
with consent from both both parties to
meet at any time so if you end up having
a board that has retired people on it or
or the ability to have a flexible
schedule you can agree to meet in the
middle of the day it doesn't restrict
that uh when both parties actually
mutually agree upon it it just keeps one
party from forcing the other to have to
meet during the middle of someone's work
day when their pay isn't protected
then I'll take any questions if you have
them thank you very much for your
testimony
um just to clarify and it was
representative Granger's question when
you said they determine the schedule
were you saying that was legal counsel
on
both sides that we're setting that
schedule yeah yeah the legal counsel and
the union negotiator yeah all right
thank you
representative avaloni thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh Mr wheel I've
taken the question
um the in the beginning of negotiations
isn't there a time frame that is listed
by the two parties
can that be negotiated to have later
meetings
um
yes you we there but there isn't in
actual practice there has not been much
back and forth it's just I'm available
at these times I don't have any other
times available for you uh it has been
my experience
thank you
for the questions representative
Bouchard thank you Mr chairman
um
do you find it fear that one School
Board member
will dictate when the times are going to
be for negotiations
I know from my experience as a
negotiator it's an agreement between
both sides
and
so
well so I don't think that it is Once In
in my particular case and experience it
wasn't just myself but the other
negotiator also had work obligations at
another school and and used up all of
their vacation time to meet this when we
we were simply asking and and operating
in good faith to say hey can we please
meet early in the morning or at three
o'clock in the afternoon still on still
on payable time
um so that you know he wouldn't have to
use up all his vacation time and and I
lose a whole day of pay as a
self-employed person I don't even get
vacation time
thank you uh follow-up is is any
procedure that both sides need to
uh
agree when you're going to meet correct
but in practice
um by saying they don't have any other
times to meet they limit the amount of
time and options that you have to meet
thank you
representative Broody thank you Mr
chairman
um
when you ask outside people like lawyers
or whatever to come in to negotiate and
they give you days when they can come in
what would you do if if you couldn't
find a day when you wanted to be there
how would you handle that
this is a schedule that that person has
a time available and if they don't have
time available that suits your schedule
what do you do
well certainly the option to find more
people in the pool of professionals to
negotiate is is always an option so that
doesn't doesn't limit you that much also
knowing that they have to negotiate
during these hours
um you know they can set their schedule
accordingly and as a school district if
we would have to retain a different
legal counsel or those options are
available to you also you're still under
this bill you're still allowed to
negotiate at any time as long as it's
actually negotiated the time and both
parties agree upon it as of right now
that's just not the practice that
happens
representative McKenzie
uh thank you for appearing and thank you
for your community service and I I
understand what you're saying how
difficult it is for people to get
together
um but that's a nature of the of the
environment in which we currently exist
and and I don't mean this in a rude way
at all but did you take this into
consideration when you decide to run to
the school board the kinds of sacrifices
that you would have to make to uh to be
part of this process
uh yeah absolutely I took that into
account
um unfortunately what was communicated
to me under the law was that there's
negotiation on when negotiations are
going to happen uh and that's just not
the practice uh and that's that's the
problem is that you know you're trying
to negotiate or you're trying to
navigate making a good decision on
whether we're to run and represent your
community uh in what is represented to
you as truth is it just wasn't it's not
the practice that's happening
um so now you find yourself in a
position where the law says one thing
and and the indications given are that
it's good uh information and that
there'll be good communication back and
forth and one side will work with the
other to make sure that everybody is
mutually represented and it's just not
the practice that I've experienced
follow-up
negotiations and I've done a little bit
of it is um it's this idea of coming
together and working through things and
uh and it's best done at the local level
so you acknowledge then that there are
the current situation allows you uh to
sit down with the with the employee
group and negotiate uh mutually
beneficial and acceptable uh times to
meet and and things like that correct
um no no I do not the the practice is
the practice set by the labor board
which is one reason why we need
legislation to clarify is that
um both sides would set 50 percent of
the schedule basically is kind of their
understanding and that what they've said
but that's not what's happening in
practice it's it's really a strong armed
we're going to meet now
um type tactic
foreign
do you have representative Granger
so uh what happens if you just say no
like if they say hey we're going to meet
this time and what if you just say no
I'm not going to do that well then
you're in violation of negotiating in
good faith okay
representative did you have one yeah
yeah oh it already answered and uh who
would I see over here representative
Broody thank you Mr chairman
um I don't I don't know how your your
District handles negotiations but don't
you have like a chief negotiator or does
the whole school board participate in
the negotiations
um we as a school board will put up two
of our school board members on a
negotiation team and also including the
superintendent HR uh assistant
superintendent our legal counsel
um the the business administrator
um and that's our negotiating team and
then when that team is done negotiating
we'll bring the full proposal back to
the board for ratification
um in I think it's important to also
note that under this bill nothing
changes about the access that the Unions
would have to teach your staff HR
um you know the the business
administrator for questions during
normal school day this this only
pertains to when we're actually going to
sit down in a room and have a two or
three hour meeting on negotiating
thank you Mr chairman so if you have a
negotiator in two school board members
what this would mean if if this didn't
go through is that you just couldn't
participate in that session but you're
still working as a team and they would
get back to you
um it's just that you don't have actual
participation in that meeting
correct as as an individual so in the
Milford school district in particularly
there's there's five school board
members and only one of them is retired
with a flexible schedule and our our
rules require two people to be there as
representation of the board
um so in this particular case somebody's
work schedule would be affected and that
depends on what they do for a living how
affected it it would be
representative Bouchard
um have you uh consulted with other
uh communities to see if they have the
same problem I I have talked to you I
know there's there's some difficulty in
Wilton New Hampshire with the
negotiations as well in the time
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
next up I would like to call Suzanne
Shaden
if I'm mispronouncing that I apologize
uh she is representing herself from
Milford she is in opposition to the bill
and it says you have written testimony I
I do I don't have copies for everyone
I'm sorry if you can just get it to the
club
um Suzanne sorry
um
nobody pronounces it correctly it's okay
I'm here to speak to the unfair
indiscriminatory nature of this bill
I'm shocked and disappointed to see that
we've singled out Educators and given
them a different set of rules for
negotiations than every other Public
Employee
stating that all public employees can
meet during the regular work day except
for teachers is discrimination how is it
fair to say that a teacher can work from
7 30 to 3 30 and then begin negotiations
at 6 pm but every other Public Employee
can meet during the workday asking
Public School teachers who volunteer to
be part of a negotiating team to only be
able to meet before 9 A.M or after 6 PM
puts an unfair burden on them stating
that it impacts instructional time is
also discriminatory negotiating during
the day means that I am working on what
makes my school district a better place
I'm working on a contract that benefits
the teachers and respects the town's tax
base my work during that time is just as
valuable as being in front of my
students I've been on negotiating teams
for the last 20 years
every time we have made a schedule that
accommodates both sides teams from both
sides are made up of people that work in
the district plus their legal
professionals
school board members do not have to be
part of the negotiating team at the
table it is their choice typically the
board has given their directions to the
superintendent and the lawyer we have
had board members present one other time
other than this past year
and they accommodated our schedules
in this past fall Mr Nathaniel who was
part of the school board representation
during our negotiation and this bill is
a clear representation of what Mr
Wheeler said during our negotiations
Mr wheel was informed that by the school
district lawyer that the law RSA 273a
requires meeting times in places that
are set by mutual agreement a law that
has been in place for many years and has
generally worked both best for both
parties Mr Wheeler did not want to meet
during the day with the teachers but he
did find time in his schedule to have
daytime meetings with for our custodial
staff's negotiations during that same
period of time
this bill is into a direct violation of
the current law the current law allows
the parties to complete mediation in
fact finding with an assigned third
party that also always works during the
normal business hours these processes
have always been completed during the
workday it would be impossible to
complete these processes before 9 A.M
and after 6 PM as a taxpayer I oppose
this bill because it will raise our
school district budgets because of the
cost of an attorney will increase
dramatically if they are required to
meet outside of normal work hours this
bill discriminates against all education
professionals why are teachers being
excluded from a reasonable negotiating
time who felt the teachers could work
from 7 30 to 3 30 and then begin in a
negotiation session at 6 PM possibly for
four hours was fair not a teacher that's
for sure
my other comment is I want to talk about
my last
our sessions for negotiations that we
had this year so I quickly looked at my
calendar we had seven sessions
and we all sat down to agree upon times
and yes you do kind of listen to what
the lawyer schedules are because this is
the toughest schedules to manage and we
work around that kind of thing but we
all work on mutually
agreeable times if we have a workshop
day as teachers we can easily catch up
on what was missed and that's always
been a brilliant time for us to have an
extended negotiation session
this past fall we attempted to negotiate
a contract and we had seven sessions
four of those sessions were from seven
to nine a.m one was from four to seven
PM two were from either one to three or
twelve to two and one was from oh one
was
nope that's it one two three four five
six seven
um so we did work around we did try to
be accommodating but we have never
really had
school board members at the table
they've always sent their direction we
get to appoint negotiations and they say
thank you we need to take this back to
the board and we come back at another
time after they've gotten more
directions this is an unfair burden I'm
asking that if you sponsored this bill
please remove don't vote for this bill
please remove your name from
consideration as Peter Petrino did he
listened and he understood that this
discriminates
I'll take questions thank you very much
for your testimony
um just to clarify in my head
were you a part of the negotiating team
for the contract in question yes okay
thank you
questions for this Witness
I was also the chief negotiator oh yes
thank you representative Susie
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
the question can you just clarify for me
who sits in on contract negotiations on
both sides
um on the school district side is the
school district's lawyer the
superintendent often the assistant
superintendent the business manager at
times the HR person that's their side on
the teacher side is the chief negotiator
myself
depending on
who volunteers kind of thing but we look
for a representative teacher from each
level someone from elementary middle and
high school and we have our our Union
representation our Nea person with us
thank you
for the questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony and if you can
come up and hand it
um I have the last card for this bill in
front of me if anyone hasn't filled out
a card and wishes to speak please make
sure that you do uh this
testimony will be from Lori Hayes who
represents the Nea New Hampshire is in
opposition to the bill and also has
written testimony
thank you
my name is Lori Hayes I'm a uniserve
director for Nea New Hampshire
prior to working I began working for Nea
New Hampshire in 2012. I'm 2007 prior to
working for Nea New Hampshire I was
Chief negotiator for the state employees
Association and I work for them
beginning in 2003. so my experience here
in New Hampshire has always been through
negotiations at no point has there been
an issue regarding planning and mutually
agreeing to dates until this school year
um I want wanted not to make this a um
about one individual but I think it's
important that some of the answers that
you receive from Mr Wheeler were not
what I remember about negotiations
I first want to say I represent three
different bargaining units in Milford a
custodial unit that begins work at 6 A.M
a paraprofessional unit that begins work
sometimes 7 30 sometimes 8 30 depending
on what school they work in and a
teacher unit and again they all Begin
work between 7 30 and 8 30. the
custodial unit would work we would meet
with the custodial unit to engage in
negotiations from 7 to 9 A.M on many
different dates Mr Wheeler never
complained about that it was during
their work day
we met recently with a paraprofessional
unit beginning at 8 AM that meeting
lasted till 11 A.M Mr Willard did not
make any complaints
when we decided to engage in
negotiations with the teachers we
actually met for at least two hours to
discuss States
we discussed States from seven to nine
as Suzanne had mentioned and as she
mentioned the super majority of the
dates were from 7 to 9 A.M
we had one day from four to seven and a
couple days from one to three
in those one to three dates were dates
in which the teachers were engaged in
professional development
Mr Wheeler to my understanding did not
present that he felt we
um bulldozed him is what I have received
from his testimony today
and to agreeing to those dates
we provided dates we went through at
least 15 or 16 different dates that we
offered he and his team went back to
their room to discuss it and they came
back and agreed to the dates that were
there
and again the super majority of them
were from 7 to 9 A.M
you know why because we mutually agreed
which is what the Public Employee Labor
Relations Board requires
I know that one of uh one of you had a
question about did this go to the Public
Employee Labor Relations Board and that
would usually occur if there was an
unfair Labor practice there was no such
unfair Labor practice filed nobody
presented again from their side that we
were not bargaining in good faith
there's just no reason for this bill to
be in place another reason there's no
reason for this bill to be in place is
because it says unless otherwise
negotiated
that's the last provision in this bill
guess what that is what's happening now
this bill really has no purpose if we
can all mutually agree and negotiate the
dates that we're planning to meet which
is always what has occurred since 1976.
but I want to get to my um testimony
um
to say I'm disappointed that you've
singled education professionals out to
force them to meet prior to 9 A.M and
after 6 PM would be an understatement
this bill places an undue burden on
public employees that are education
professionals that is not placed on
other public employees the bill is
unfair the bill would make negotiating
in a school setting impossible
especially for Education support
professionals who happen to work two or
three jobs after work
to my knowledge and after many years of
negotiations I believe there has only
been one person that has so continuously
disagreed with the notion that the dates
and times per negotiations are to be
mutually decided that they would request
that this bill be created
RSA 273a has already been determined to
require negotiations dates and times
that are mutually agreed the New
Hampshire Public Employee Relations
Board has made that ruling in case law
the law currently requires meeting dates
are set by mutual agreement
mutual agreement has worked to set
negotiations dates since the lab was
first implemented in 1976.
I also want to say that mutual agreement
negotiation dates and times have been
set prior to 9 A.M sometimes at 1 pm
sometimes at 6 pm
all by mutual agreement all as necessary
to complete negotiations in a timely
manner and have peaceful labor relations
in the school setting
this bill will as Suzanne explain raise
taxpayer funding there are a
attorneys that represent school boards
and those attorneys don't normally work
at 7 A.M and don't normally work after 6
PM they work normal attorney hours which
are usually nine to five
and requiring them to come and work from
seven to nine and then again from 6 pm
to God knows when it makes no sense
negotiations sometimes take place for
two hours sometimes they play take place
for four hours but they're usually an
all-day process when we are engaged in
mediation and when we are engaged in
fact finding which are part of RSA 273a
if it is required that education
professionals negotiate prior to 9 A.M
and negotiate after 6 PM you've
basically cut off their ability to use
the process that's currently in place in
the law
um
and Milford and when I began working in
Milford in 2012
I would negotiate with the
superintendent and an attorney
representing on the school board
it was not until 2019 that one School
Board member joined us in negotiation
this school board member came to the
table we mutually agreed on times and
dates to meet and we engaged in
negotiations
since that time we have always met
during the work day especially to engage
in Grievances and other things like that
we engaged in negotiations with school
board members during the work day and at
no time have I ever heard other than
today that it was an undue burden on one
particular School Board member as you
know in Milford there are five school
board members there are there's one that
I know is available during the day she's
retired there is a second one that I I
understand
um Works um as a commuter from home he's
available during the day never had a
problem with him engaging in
negotiations during the work day the
only person that has ever engaged in a
problem is Mr Wheeler no one else I
would hate for us to make a Statewide
law that that benefits just one person
without benefiting the super majority of
our taxpayers
um there was one statement made that
this law is beneficial to the school
board member
RSA 273-a is actually made for the
benefit of both labor and management not
for one party over the other
so again I would ask you to please vote
in expedient to legislate this law
thank you very much for your testimony
are there questions
I see none uh oh I do see what
representative peruty thank you Mr
chairman
um thanks for your testimony um
the school board member is newly added
in the last few years
um does that school board member
actually participate in negotiations or
they just sit at the table and more or
less observe we know that negotiations
that I took part of and I was a chief
negotiator
I was the only one that spoke and I
would get advice from people but they
really didn't have input except through
me through the chair is that how it is
in Milford that is exactly how it works
in Milford today
thank you
any further questions
thank you again for your testimony if
you have a written copy could you get it
to the clerk
is it possible for me to send it later I
wrote all over it that's that's fine
thank you thank you and as I said that
was the last card that I have
representative baroody if you could get
the blue sheet for this bill and pass it
forward
have an understanding of the numbers for
assignments online I
don't
um
and
our res I think our researcher was
getting that and she's not here so if we
can get that later on okay yeah sure
I have the I don't have a a printout of
the online sign ins but in terms of the
physical sign-ins
there were five signed in opposed to
this bill and two signed in in favor
with that we are in recess until
10 45 so uh a little more than five
minutes and we'll pick up with the next
bill thank you
foreign
interesting
members of the committee I see 10 45 on
the clock so if we could
retake our seats we can get started with
the next hearing
give a chance I don't have to yell it
here we go
I would like to open the hearing on Bill
number 410 and I recognize the prime
sponsor representative Pearson to
introduce his bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the labor committee
for having us here today
for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 which
encompasses the town of Derry
House Bill 410
involves something that
New Hampshire typically has not really
spent much time on here
so I'll go over the premise of why this
is here
what the bill says is that if you're in
a municipality that uses
A ranked promotional type system
that you'll have the your department
head would have the ability
based on the collective bargaining
agreement to go down and pick a superior
candidate
which does happen
and then at that point they would go in
order
the purpose of establishing a
promotional list
is to find your top candidate your most
qualified candidate that is why they do
ranked promotional lists
now the criteria of said promotional
lists varies from community community
depends on what the
Community Values in their people
specifically
it's not uniform across the state
and in most cases it's part of the
collective bargaining agreement with
whatever your
labor forces
that's the purpose of establishing a
promotional list
now in the state of New Hampshire
our citizens have equal opportunity
to advance themselves in their careers
from the day you're hired you should
have an opportunity to rise
to whatever level you're willing to
Aspire to to try to obtain
to put your best foot forward
and frankly it's in the public interest
to have the most qualified people in
leadership positions
in municipalities and local government
the taxpayers pay salaries to have the
most qualified people in those positions
and the system that we have in place is
through a promotional process
too often
we see people that seem to be out of
place
and you get that whisper on the side of
Hey That's so-and-so's nephew or that so
and so son
and it's become in my 20 over 20 years
now of public service so blatant so
common that it's considered accepted
yeah that's the way the system is that's
the way things go it just happens
well that flies in the face of us having
equal opportunity
to advance ourselves
we should not be operating our local
municipalities
as if we're still under the feudal
system of the British Empire
just because someone in your family did
something does not entitle you to
anything your hard work your dedication
your willingness to educate yourself
that is part of how America works
we don't use a feudal system anymore
now the thing that was probably most
upsetting to me is the folks that I've
seen this suffer from this over time
that I've talked to about potentially
coming up here today
one gave me the fact that it was a
scheduling conflict
but three others said to me there's no
way I'm going to come up and testify on
this because I am in fear of Retribution
of what will happen if I do so
I am not in fear of Retribution
so I will speak for this issue without
fear of that
and that's the basic premise of this
concept is that for too long
we've just had the whisper of hey that's
his uncle it's his nephew it's his
brother-in-law
and that that's got to stop
so in the sense of what this bill does
not do is it doesn't lock things up
tight in some states when you have
ranked promotional lists that's it
and there is a municipality in state in
the our state that does have that in
their collective bargaining agreement
they go in order that's the decision
that was negotiated between that labor
force and its community
but for most
that doesn't exist they don't have that
it's it's a varying of of things
as to how they make their decisions
and it's gotten to the point where you
look at this and go well
if the if the promotionalist has no
relevancy why do you even do it why do
you even have a process
because it in essence it's a sham you
you just kind of do what you want anyway
so again not getting to the tightness of
of some of the other states this does
give the carve out for that Superior
candidate that does exist in some cases
where a man you know a department head
can reach down and say okay yes you you
did not necessarily do as well and the
system is in the framework that we have
with someone else but because you have
something that's above and beyond that
puts you way over the top we're going to
be able to grab you I did not want to
lose that ability for a manager to do
that
but after that Superior candidate has
been grabbed
in essence the process should allow
itself to continue
and hence the the language stating
that once that occurs you must go in
order
that is the basic premise of this bill
I am certainly welcome questions from
what any of you on this
and we'll see where this goes
thank you very much for your testimony I
do have a couple questions
um first of all since I don't have the
rest of this section in front of me
I want to get clear in my mind does this
new letter apply
um
does it require that you use rank lists
or does it only apply if you're already
using the rank list it only applies to
municipalities in
in the language when it defines this
does not include the state and it does
not include the counties this is just
cities and towns
and in the language that uses a ranked
list so if you don't use a lot of small
communities don't use rank lists at all
some have pass fail some are so tiny
it's they look at two guys in the room
and go well okay you know this is this
is all I have doesn't apply to them at
all it just applies to municipalities
that go through the process of having a
ranked scored promotional list
all right thank you that helps me the
second question I have is the language
that you can pass over an eligible
candidate one time
is that intended to apply to the
top-ranked candidate only or everyone
down the list everyone down the list
okay yep so in essence if you were to
promote the first person if it just
happened to work out that way then you
haven't met any of the criteria you can
that's one time so for for circumstances
where they're
where they don't where they go in order
as as I feel they should it's not it's a
non-issue
all right thank you very much are there
other questions
let's start with representative love
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh what's the criteria for
the ranking uh is it testing job
performance uh it varies from Community
to community but typically you'll have
some sort of a written exam a practical
exam uh some sort of of points for
seniority in some cases some points for
your education level things of that
nature make up sometimes it involves a
an interview is the interview with the
department head is scored and it kind of
all encompasses itself into a final
score that's that's pretty much typical
across the board it varies a little bit
as far as value and stuff and that's
that's something that's determined
between the community and the in the
department typically through their
collective bargaining agreement thank
you
representative soucy
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative take my question
from someone that knows the system
um being on NASA 5 of 29 years served on
the executive board for 17 years
negotiated contracts many contracts and
I see the promotional process change
many times not to everyone's likings
maybe not to my likings
but understandably
um
negotiating fairly and making changes so
do you have the opportunity at any time
prior to contract negotiations of
putting in a contract proposal that
would change the way the promotional
system in Manchester is changed what
um going what it's at because in Nashua
we put in contract proposals if we don't
like something to make changes do you
have that opportunity in Manchester to
do the same
help me out with what you mean by you
so like this does their collective
bargaining unit have the ability to
negotiate terms of their promotional
process yes
yes they do have you follow up
follow-up
have you and your time on Manchester
fire
ever propose a change to the system
because obviously it appears that it's
not liked
I'm assuming yes okay and has one more
one more has any change come about
um there have been attempts to make it
worse
by the municipality
I'm not looking this isn't specific to
the city of Manchester but there have
been attempts to to basically nullify
the entire thing and literally just go
with the
I'll pick who I want type of system
the other way it's going the other way
so
but this is this is something I've seen
not just in the city of Manchester as
far as
name tags and last names and
questionable
lengths of service for the per you know
the positions people hold and things
like that that's
not just in Manchester I've seen this
representative Granger
so in line eight nine and ten it talks
about collective bargaining agreements
uh does this bill require collective
bargaining and is it the case that every
town in municipality in New Hampshire
uses collective bargaining it does not
require collective bargaining
at all but it says that if the if there
is criteria used to create a rank list
then it's subject to the collective
bargaining agreement that exists within
that Community if you have one but it
doesn't require collective bargaining
and just if I may clarify that statement
a little bit it's in the section of law
273 that applies to collective
bargaining so this law would not apply
if there isn't a collective bargaining
process
representative McKenzie
I can't hear you sir all right
y from the
disclosure uh we're in the same Union
come from the same fire department
worked on the same station in uh in
Manchester uh but I
I I I'd like your just your sense uh
because you've been you've been uh in a
situation have been passed by correct
I have okay so give me a sense of what
that's like as a as somebody who is on
the fire department sure I've had
working partners that have gone through
that situation I've had people that have
just decided to give up
because yeah systems rigged I'm just
giving up I'm not even going to try
anymore and that's that probably is a
supervisor to me is more disheartening
than anything else when you have someone
that has a passion and a desire to serve
the public who now just throws their
hands up because it doesn't matter what
I do
um we've had I had a working partner who
whose situation led to some drastic
results I've had folks that I've seen in
in various firehouses that have spent
years
at the fire academy years in in college
night school doing everything they can
to advance themselves
simply dismissed because
of what I would consider something that
was discriminatory
rather than based on the merits of of
the process
and it's it's completely demoralizing
not just to an individual but to an
institution an agency as well
follow up
we have in the fire service developed
standards for pretty much everything
from the boots we wear to the mass that
we wear
is there a place in anywhere in the
system where uh and I do this in my own
Peril suggests this foot uh is there is
there any uh rationale or reason why we
would put a a system for promotions
within the within the standards and
training
you know different communities value
different things they have specific
needs
that they feel are unique perhaps
so to to place a a standard within the
New Hampshire fire standards training
with authority in essence to uniform
that I don't know that that would be
I think you would you you would take
away a bit of a community's individual
perspective and needs with that and I
don't I don't know that I would be in
favor of such a thing
a final question final question
when you were uh passed over as a uh as
a candidate
what was the uh what were you given as
criteria for being passed over
um in my in my particular case and in
others particular case the the section
of the collective bargaining agreement
was repeated
the
you know the administrator has the right
to blah blah there was never feedback
there was never any sort of this is why
there none of that it's they just quoted
out of uh out of a collective bargaining
agreement
um as to the justification of what what
occurred
which I don't I don't think is I mean
that's a whole nother issue but I think
that's certainly not beneficial to
developing your people when that's the
answer that's provided to someone
thank you Walter
thank you are there other questions
represented babyloni
thank you Mr chairman um so you're
looking to redefine
Public Employee
specifically for a city or a town
and a public we Define a public employer
which only means a city or town
in this sub paragraph
only
I'm reading
on line 10. in this subparagraph only
the purpose of that was to make it clear
who the players are in this case that
doesn't redefine the term in statute
anywhere else
and just in this sub paragraph it clear
it's a clarification it's not a
redefinition
under Title 9 11 of the definitions in
273 a which is this is part of terms and
conditions of employment so you're
looking to redefine the terms and
conditions of a public employer to
overrule their organizational structure
that is not what this says
I'll clarify that for me because
this is telling you you can only
which if we passed it uh shall only one
time in the life of the promotionalist
so if you have a 30-year employee that's
been passed over once
a promotionalist five years ago and it's
not still not ready for a
that's not how that works so promotional
lists have a life span to them anywhere
from a year two years three years and
then they hold a subsequent
um
exam that they're not lifetime lists it
that would also hold true if you changed
administrators
so if you change an administrator that
starts so it resets as well because you
have a new administrator who has a
different potentially set of of
priorities in their criteria so
um
this is not an infinite
circumstance
it it expires when the list expires oh
well
um and I know there's been talk of fire
and police have you given thought to
like DPW departments or anything like
that that sure might have a promotional
list but not be part of a CBA
again if they don't have a a
collective bargaining agreement this
this is not applicable to them because
it's it it references that it must again
in the beginning part where
um it mentions that the criteria shall
be subject to the collective bargain
agreement in effect at the time if they
don't have a collective bargaining
agreement it's it's irrelevant if they
if they don't use a promotional process
that ranks or scores if they have a pass
fail as an example this is not relevant
to that because you you don't you can't
rank pass fail
thank you thank you for the
clarification representative thank you
Mr chairman
uh representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question sure um
reading this and how it changes how the
um the the
promotion list would be used
could the same thing that this is this
bill is trying to accomplish be
accomplished on a municipality by
municipality level by putting it into
the bargain contract
so what happens is as you guys are well
aware being this is the labor committee
you have a process of back and forth
and
a lot of times
you do not have the ability you you know
there are certain things that are
brought to the table there are certain
things that are immediately off the
table on both sides
and to to ask in an administrator or a
department head to
um
surrender power
rare you know is rarely successful so
this is the this is the sense of you
know
as
as in is it the purpose of a republic is
to
um
basically stand for the minority stand
for the those that are
um
that don't necessarily have the power
and might to stand and force things that
that is the function of this is to
to say in New Hampshire
we're not going to allow
arbitrary discriminatory decision making
in a promotional process when we have a
set of criteria that is established that
puts you in a ranking order based on
qualifications
thank you
any further questions
let me ask representative Cahill first
and then I'll come to you
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Pearson uh you mentioned that they often
use an interview which I think is
subjective is that is that something
that could be used to manipulate the uh
the outcome of the list even if you
didn't have this the it would depend
certainly on the weight that is that is
provided to that interview
as far as you know when you're when
you're typically using a point structure
right to create a ranked list the value
of that interview
in reference to other parts is a
negotiated item
that also allows the circumstance where
a department head
has to deal with a candidate who is an
excellent test taker but yet lacks
certain
either character criteria or just you
know the ability to to lead that where
that can be taken
and balanced out so I I would you know I
don't
I'm not advocating to remove any sort of
type of
of criteria used to establish a list
that is between the the collective
bargaining unit in it in its
municipality so I don't want to
interfere with that that's that's their
decision what I'm saying is once they
set the rules
and everybody agrees to whatever those
rules are
then
you've established your promotional list
use it and use it in order
follow up follow up so you would give
them one bite at the Apple to uh change
to use different to avoid the criteria
and following that they would follow the
criser rate and it would depend on the
collective bargaining agreement in some
municipalities their collective
bargaining agreement says they go in
order and some says that they can choose
out of the top three candidates and
that's typically done because the scores
may be really close together and it's
supposed to be used to grab a superior
candidate that has things that don't
necessarily fit within the framework of
the rigid
point system that is a that exists that
that's the purpose of it and I don't
necess I don't want to take that ability
away for for them to do that but I'm
saying that if you have a superior
candidate then you get one shot at the
superior candidate and then you're going
to have to go in order thank you
representative Susie
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
so the bargaining unit
has your opportunity
I would assume
to
hold up
the negotiation process to hold up
something if they felt that the
promotional process was a very vital
thing to the membership
if they didn't like what they saw or
what's in the current contract they
could actually hold up
that negotiations until either side
gives or they move on to something else
is that correct
they could sure any any criteria in a
collective bargain agreement can end
negotiations sure
thank you representative love
that's weird
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question
um as far as a collective bargaining uh
unit goes uh are all members so say ufia
Department the members of One collective
bargaining unit or uh lieutenants have
their own little one and the captains uh
they are not in this particular case and
also too remember under the Janus
decision you are not required
to be in a labor union
so you have the right to
to not participate in that
that's that's not just that's a whole
country under the Janus decision so
at that point who how do we who speaks
for those people
follow up
so
the the rank and file is made up more of
um in in your case uh vitamin okay and
uh you know you being a lieutenant uh
and the the the the lower lower ranked
firemen uh really don't care too much
about what happens to you uh if they if
they're getting a a good pay raise uh
would your uh your ability to move up
the the kick to the curb uh in
negotiations
that that really involves intent
representative love and I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna speak to that that's
that's that's a hypothetical that I
I'm not going to codify well I've I've
had personal experience with
representative do you have a follow-up
question
um no that's okay thank you
uh are there any other questions
representative McKenzie
uh at some point in your testimony
uh you you referred to uh what I think
is a serious matter which is
discriminatory
um practices am I accurate in saying
that you refer to that at some point
during the course of this and if you if
you did could you
um
we've collected buying environments and
we have all of those things that can
take place and you mentioned
discriminatory practices can you expand
I can give you one in particular because
the
try this again
okay
turn it on again try it again nope
wow all right um maybe if I speak a
little bit away from it that might be
more helpful uh in in one particular
case
representative amelani
thank you
it doesn't work there it is
um if your municipality has a ordinance
that has a structure in place
and it's not subject to bargaining would
this overrule those ordinances or
anything like that
you're saying in their coordinates a
promotional process correct
I don't believe that it would because
that's not afflict of carbony
function do you have an example of a
community that has their promotional
profits in their ordinances I'm looking
at
273-a colon 3 section 3. manage
regarding the policies and practice of
any Merit system established by Statute
Charter ordinance relating to
recruitment examination appointment and
advancement under conditions of
political neutrality and based upon
principles of Merit and confidence shall
not be subjects of bargaining under the
provisions of this chapter are you
looking to rewrite that with this or
change it
probably not it's very specific to
Collective bargain and I'd love to I'd
love to know what community has their
promotions
it does enable them but actually I'd
just be surprised to hear that because
I've never heard that
thank you for the clarification thank
you Mr chairman
is that gonna oh hey look at that
uh just reboot
sounds good mine does anyway
are there any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for oh there we go
up next and
um
if that's still distorted we might want
to try on
hello okay
I will say that ranking Democrat is
watching from
YouTube
so I I don't want to embarrass myself
mispronouncing a name again so I would
ask Stephen
and
smuggula
who is representing the Concord Police
Department and is speaking in opposition
to the bill
uh thank you and if
turn if you could turn that on with the
button please thank you is that work can
you guys hear me all right uh Mr
chairman thank you very much for your
time uh uh members of the committee
thank you very much my name is Stephen
smigula I'm a lifelong resident of the
State of New Hampshire and
um 26 plus year police officer for the
city at Concord
I currently hold the rank of
currently hold the rank of uh deputy
chief so a fair and Equitable
promotional process it mean a lot to me
I've been through many of them I've been
successful in some of them
um
concerned with the language as written
the reason why I posed this is Concord
is one of those committees or excuse me
communities that actually
promotional process governed by
ordinance
so I was concerned coming in here uh the
impact I've made that uh you know this
would not impact the way we do
operations in Concord because
obtained solely in a CBA
but I do have concerns that while we do
have our guidance from city ordinance
cbas change all the time we just closed
our last uh
literally uh
um and I guess uh what I really uh
oppose is it seems to me that if you
pass somebody over in in Concord we we
have the ability by ordinance pick from
anyone in the top three and and we're
trying to get our best candidates in the
in the right positions uh to to benefit
the organization
uh we also have uh the public Integrity
unit which is new to the state and for
police officers uh while this is
uncommon I can certainly Envision during
the time where a promotional process
kicks off and you have a ranking and and
the time in which you're actually moving
to fill that vacancy to to promote
somebody that uh what would we do if
something came up and you got notified
as a department that one of your top
three were under investigation by the
AGS for an alleged act
what would you do you'd pass them over
uh and that would automatically mean the
next time you do a promotion within the
life of that promotion you would have to
promote them what happens if you didn't
have a response back from the AGS this
is a real occurrence it does happen
you know without getting into uh
specifics I have an officer out on leave
uh and it's his fourth month and we're
waiting for uh some sort of guidance
from them and and I can't help but think
what would I do if this was relevant to
to the city of Concord and uh we
promoted two people in that four-month
time period which at our rate of
turnover is very possible and would we
be in a position where we would have to
make that promotion
uh and then God forbid you'll learn
something afterwards where you'd have to
uh deal with that as an internal matter
in in demote or something like that I
just think uh the overall intent might
be uh uh Noble but I think there's a lot
of facets here that need to be thought
about and how it impacts other agencies
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um
relating back you spoke about an
ordinance that you have to select your
top three yes sir so there was an
ordinance already in place for your
promotional process in certain instances
that is correct
thank you thank you Mr chairman
so this is worth
there you go
Chief thanks for the uh coming today and
providing a testimony
so Mike my question is uh centered
around the whole question of of um
of somebody being passed over without
good without just cause and could you
explain what your process is when you
make a selection and how you document
your decisions
sure our selections are are the end
result of a rigorous process
we have a written test we have
interviews and then there's a component
for things like experience and and
Longevity so that we're making sure that
the folks that we're promoting uh have
the work experience that we're setting
them up for success
um
we end up inviting folks from the
community to participate in our
promotion process as well we take all
that input and it gets referred back to
the department head so in the police
department that would be the chief of
police
and then those movements are made based
on a ranking so a roster is produced
it's all numerically based and uh he has
the the latitude to pick from that top
three
all right follow up thank you
so for for a candidate who is in the top
three and gets passed over
uh
how were they uh able to look at what
that process was and understand why it
is that they were passed over subjective
objective kind of environment
so all our process uh you know there are
score sheets there are Raider reports
that kind of thing uh any any candidate
in a process can go back up to our
professional development unit and get
full disclosure of those notes the
selections they they know the the whole
list and and that affords a great uh
opportunity for uh the lieutenant in
charge of our professional development
unit to actually touch upon reasons why
uh they were passed over maybe it was a
Personnel issue and there wasn't enough
time and distance between the uh the
closure of that Personnel issue and the
timing of a promotion you know um and
and like I said I've put in for many
promotions and been successful in some
so I appreciate not you know getting uh
What uh what you had wanted
thank you
representative Holcomb thank you Mr
chair for taking my question
um
do you have in your criteria
for your ranking do you have an
affirmative action criteria that you
also use that may actually
um
rise above maybe where somebody is
scored and ranked in the process
are you referring to like a waiting
um
uh
yeah I mean is there is there a
requirement that needs to meet the
affirmative action
um where you have so many people in that
in that category that need to be
promoted or should be promoted above
maybe somebody else who has scored
higher
uh the best example I can use and sorry
I'm going to make this personal
um when my husband was taking the test
for the State Police in Massachusetts he
scored a 98 plus but was passed over by
somebody who scored in the low 80s
because they had to meet an affirmative
action criteria so I'm just curious if
that is something that's part of the
criteria that you're working with here
in New Hampshire no it's not
are there any further questions
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
um do you often advertise outside of
your department for certain positions
uh we do and would they follow please
yeah thank you my apologies
um would they be part of that ranking
process even though you might have
officers in place that might be
qualified for that job
yes example of that is currently I'm
hiring for uh police dispatch supervisor
that is a congruent uh process we have
uh internal candidates and we're taking
external candidates as well and both
will go on to that same ranking
any further questions
okay
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for your time
up next I would like to call David
Goldstein who is representing the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police in opposition to the bill
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee
take a moment and I did score 98 on the
Mass state police exam I didn't get the
job
I did not get the job
my name for the record is David
Goldstein I'm the chief in the city of
Franklin
and I represent the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police and we
are in oppositioning this bill HP 410
now you can only speak quite frankly to
police matters as far as this issue is
concerned but I think it might be
applicable to other uh professions as
well
I'm going to give you a little bit of my
pedigree and my history because I think
it's important here
I've been a police officer for over 43
years
if you include my part-time work it's
been 45 years
I've been passed over so many times I
like to tell people I got athlete Scout
quite frankly and that is humorous
I may I heard someone mention academic
requirements I have a bachelor's degree
two master's degrees and a PhD
and I have soon been passed over for
promotion
I've been a police chief all toll for 19
years the first five
um first five of those 19 was for the
town of Winthrop Massachusetts
the last 14 years have been in the city
of Franklin
I started my career back in 1979 full
time
worked for the Derry Police Department
for three years went to the state police
for the next 23 years where I retired as
a uniform captain
took that five-year Hiatus went down to
Massachusetts as chief where I'm from
and came back uh lovingly so to New
Hampshire never gave up my New Hampshire
address by the way and uh have been in
Franklin ever since
we have to look at this a little bit
differently from our perspective while
Manchester might be the largest city in
the state Franklin is the smallest of
the 13 cities and yet we still have some
of the similar issues that we're
discussing here today
I don't understand a little bit as to
why this is just City and towns
as a trooper as a member of the state
police
I was passed over many times uh until I
finally made rank
and I would think that this would be
applicable to both state and County
promotions as well
in the Civil when I was in Massachusetts
we dealt with something called civil
service and I'm going to bring that up
because my fear
my abject fear is that we are going to
become a Massachusetts and I ask you not
to do that
in Massachusetts when I was Chief there
we had Civil Service I had no choice
it was promote the first person on the
list that was uh that the uh it tests uh
resulted in however there were
Exceptions there were as you put it
affirmative action Exceptions there were
disability Exceptions there were
veterans exceptions and it was something
that is lovingly referred to in
Massachusetts as the layoff list
and the layout list is if I laid off an
officer and some of them chose to do
that they could then apply to another
civil service department and they
immediately went to the top of the list
over everybody else irrespective of
their abilities and capabilities we
don't want that
at that time my department was under a
20-year consent decree because of
minority issues and affirmative action
issues that we were experiencing the
consent decree had been signed by a
former Chief who had absolutely no legal
right to do so but because it had been
in place so long it took on the the
position of being a law
it took me three years to show civil
service that my department in its
minority makeup actually needed that of
the town
but it took me three years to do that
at first as I said the um in order to
get promoted you had to be first on the
list some of the other exceptions
noteworthy as well however then they
went to the top three and my question at
that point in time was why top three
so if I like a but not b and I kind of
like C I can then choose among three so
it's kind of this the same thing that's
being talked about here today
a failure system was known for promoting
people that shouldn't have been promoted
because they were good test takers but
were they good cops that was the problem
it was no measure for their ability as
police officers there was a great
measure for their ability to take a test
and trust me I've taken a lot of tests
in my time
when I wanted finally to promote from
Patrol the sergeant I called civil
service and I said
how do I do that oh we don't have a
process for that
and I was very concerned and I said what
do I do and they said make one up sure I
did
and they went up that was numerically
based and I was able to promote a
sergeant from that particular list
but I found that to be as I say strange
I should say she will make it possible
for a department to abandon objective
criteria as well and I would mention
this while my department is not clear
nor State accredited while State
accredited we will be applying for State
accreditation I was reminded by Chiefs
who are Kalia and Kalia stands for the
commission on accreditation for law
enforcement agencies that should this
become law that undermines Kalia
requirements in other words uh as I was
told we have to consider the fact that
both federal and state standards for
accreditation container requirements for
the promotional process itself must use
performance reviews for Kalia and state
accreditation and this uh this is a good
test you might have a good test taker
but not a great talk as I mentioned
something to keep in mind as well
this legislation presumes on the
objective processes when any good
promotional process does involve
subjective criteria the department it
has to be allowed to use his or her good
judgment good sense to make a final
decision vis-a-vis the best employee for
promotion for that particular Department
should this become law I can assure you
the Departments without Collective
borrowing agreement guidelines will shy
away and from those with Collective
burning agreements and the guidelines
will not be the same
on his face
this is not a Despicable concept it
means a lot to people but in practice a
diminution of the ability
for those in command to establish the
best department they know how we know
our communities
we know our communities you know the
people that can best serve our
communities and contrary to popular
belief I can and as I said can only
speak to police departments we're not a
democracy we're still in autocracy in a
police department
we are of necessity that way
is there a possible solution
uh is this a possible solution in search
of a problem that's the question that I
have to ask thank you for listening and
I'll be happy to entertain any questions
you might have thank you for your
testimony are there questions
representative valwani
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um the city of Concord has ordinances
pertaining to promotionalists it and not
asking you for all of the towns that you
represent but do you know of any others
that might have that ordinance in place
I do not thank you
thank you Mr other questions
representative McKenzie
thank you just don't call me late for
lunch
can you talk about
um
and knowing you're sitting me
understand when you do the best bandages
that's a very good question and quite
frankly
um there are a number of different ways
to approach that and that is on a more
personal level that we would do
something like that so if a candidate
came to me and they have and said why
didn't I get promoted we would talk a
little bit about that and it might be as
I said anything could be performance
review issue could be disciplinary
issues in the past it could just be that
they just didn't show uh what I consider
uh the necessary
aspects we need in order to take on that
particular role
um it's not a perfect system by any
stretch on either side it wouldn't be a
perfect system if you if you voted this
into law it's not a perfect system on
the subjective side I'm sure everybody
in this room who's worked in any kind of
hierarchical environment has been passed
over for a position or has wanted
something and not got it so it hurts
there's no question as I said I've been
passed over as the deputy said many
times times quite frankly and sometimes
scratched my head and went home and when
I was alone screamed into the pillow but
other than that uh that that also is a
fact of life that we have to live by at
this point in time we can't legislate
this
they can't legislate this you can't
legislate human dealings and and
emotions it just doesn't work so the
best approach that I've used in the past
is let's sit down and talk about it
because I do have an open door policy
whatever that's what
any other questions
I see none so thank you very much for
your testimony thank you I have one
final card for this bill
um if there's anybody else who hasn't
filled out a card please do so this is
natch Grace he is representing New
Hampshire Municipal Association and
opposes the Bill thank you Mr chair and
H Grace from Municipal Association as
stated I opposed the bill
um the the officers ahead of me said
most everything I wanted to say so be
very brief
um I've heard from my my members uh
several of them that they're very
concerned that if passed this would
essentially require them to either keep
open a position that they're looking to
promote someone into or fill it with an
unsuitable candidate that the specific
examples that I was provided related to
someone who is potentially under
investigation by the AG's office
obviously we all know what the headline
would be if they were promoted
and if the AG's office came down and
said that uh you know they found some
sort of wrongdoing there
um and municipalities don't want to be
in that position they want the ability
to uh to to avoid that uh headline in
WMUR
um and the other example that I was
specifically given was there are
situations where employees come forward
they say to their employers you know I'm
having uh mental health issues can you
work with me the employer works with
them but they may be on this
pre-existing list and it would be unfair
to them and unfair to the employer to
put them in a new situation at that time
simply because that would cause new
stressors
um and that would not necessarily work
out for everyone involved so those were
the two major concerns and I won't
repeat everything that the officer said
ahead of me because I think they covered
basically everything else
thank you very much for that testimony I
have a question there was a a question
earlier
about
we've heard about police and fire how
might this affect differently other
departments within a city in town could
it impact schools does that fit in the
definition are there other issues that
might be outside of police and fire yes
so my understandings would affect
anywhere where there is a collective
bargaining agreement I don't have a
comprehensive list of every Department
that that might be collectively
bargaining although the state obviously
does
um but there are Public Works
departments that that are have collected
bargaining agreements there are schools
that obviously their teacher collective
bargaining agreements I don't represent
teachers so I don't I don't follow that
closely but they those do exist
um so there are other departments and
there are some municipalities I believe
that the administrators uh so kind of
the front office staff are also
unionized as well
thank you
other questions
representative McKenzie thank you
in a case of promotional system uh
we to my knowledge we haven't done so
recently uh but that's a good suggestion
and I'll make that as soon as I get back
to the office and if if we can find
something I'll let you know
other questions
representative probe
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um we heard that the city of Concord has
an ordinance regarding promotions are
you aware of any other cities or towns
uh in either police fire context or
other contexts that specify that by
ordinance I knew someone was going to
ask me that and I should have said in
the beginning I don't have an answer for
your ordinance question I'm sorry
seeing that
in the Black Edition uh thank you very
much for your testimony
um that was the final card that I had on
this bill and seeing no one else I will
close the hearing on 410. I'll hold off
on the blue sheet until we are a little
bit behind so I'd like to open the
hearing on HB 561 and ask the sponsor
representative Wendy Thomas to introduce
the bill
foreign
go ahead okay thank you Mr chair and
members of the labor industrial and
rehabilitative services committee I am
representative Wendy Thomas here I'll
take this off representing the town of
Merrimack and I come before you today to
introduce House Bill 561 which is
establishing a committee to examine
Workforce and school accommodations for
those with long-term covid and mecfs
as a little bit of background one of my
degrees is in medical biology and I
worked for years as a clinical
microbiologist
long covid is often a debilitating
illness that occurs in at least 10 and
as much as 30 percent of covid
infections more than 200 symptoms have
been identified with impacts on multiple
organ systems at least 65 million
individuals worldwide are estimated to
have long covid with CR with cases
increasing daily the article that I just
sent you it's a technical article but if
you turn to page three which has the
graphic you can see some of the symptoms
that are associated with long covid
some of them obviously very debilitating
uh myalgic
encephalomyelitis is uh is also also
called chronic fatigue syndrome or mecfs
is a long-term viral-induced condition
with a wide range of symptoms the most
common symptom is extreme tiredness
other common symptoms include muscle
pain pain in the joints headaches sore
throat gastrointestinal system symptoms
sensitivity to light chills visual
disturbances nausea and allergies you'll
notice that there are a lot of
similarities
we are not quite sure of the mechanism
but it's looking like some viruses
remain in people's bodies creating havoc
in the case of children we are going to
see behavioral disorders cognitive
issues and very real body issues many of
these children will need special
education services with accommodations
to allow them to stay in school
some children may need remote access to
school we are going to need to be
creative on what we can do to protect
these kids and give them every
opportunity they can every opportunity
to stay in school
adults are also seeing these symptoms
and are are going to see similar health
issues that will impact their ability to
work
in a recent presentation to the Nashua
Chamber of Commerce and I sent everyone
a copy of this presentation by email
The Economist that gave the presentation
did not think we are heading into a
recession but he does have concerns
about the workforce and if you look at
slide 11 on the presentation which
I don't know if you can see it but this
is basically there's just a downtrend
um
his concern is about the workforce our
state's biggest challenge to growth is
our labor force it's recovering but it
remains below pre a pandemic of numbers
when I specifically asked him about uh
why the numbers were depressed in New
Hampshire he gave a few reasons one is
um he the social media influencers are
not being recorded as working he also
said that women have left the force in
large numbers to take care of their
children who have been sick and he also
said that because some people have
gotten long coveted and have become
debilitated that they have been removed
from our Workforce
uh simply put we need more workers
employees with long coveted mecfs
employees may need legal protections and
accommodations
it may be that they are part-time
workers or that they need a chair to sit
in while they're doing their work or
they may need time to nap if we want
these workers to contribute to the
workforce again
once again we're going to have to be
creative
some questions that we can consider what
limitations is the student or employee
experiencing how do these limitations
affect the employee and the employee's
job performance or the students school
performance and what specific tasks are
problematic as a result of these
limitations
uh in the email that I sent you I also
um there there was a link to a website
for mecfs and at the bottom of the link
there are uh examples of accommodations
for many of the symptoms that that show
so people are working on this issue
around the United States this is a new
problem and it's a big problem this bill
proposes a study committee so that we
can hear from patients Physicians
employees employers and even teachers
the goal is to see if we can provide any
legislative solutions to keep those with
long covid and macfss CFS in the
workforce and in schools thank you and
I'll take any questions thank you very
much for your testimony are there
questions
yes representative Schultz
thank you
um first I'd like to say if you have
testimony that's written as the clerk
I'd like to request it
um sure my questions are two quick ones
first
um
would you believe you're the first
person to make the connection between
covid and the impact on our Workforce in
the state house that I know of well I
hope I'm not the last
and second
question so why just on the surface I
realize you're you're build just is
asking for a study committee
um but on the surface why wouldn't
existing laws around
um disability and impairment at work
cover
the concerns that you've raised
um there's a few answers to that one is
that um
this is a new problem and we're not we
haven't seen the numbers that we're
going to be seeing um in the past
um secondly
because of
testing and everything it's difficult to
identify to to completely diagnose
someone as having long covet we're still
working on that
um
I'll use myself as an example I got
coveted in 2020 and suffered ill effects
for the next two years
there was no test to to prove that I had
had covid because I had covid prior to
um the the testing that was available
I've since had antibody testing which
has proven that I've been exposed to it
so it's
I I think you're heading in the right
direction there should be disability
um
protections but I think it's going to be
difficult accessing those protections
for a while
any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
oh yeah
thank you if you wish to speak make sure
and you can do it you can speak first
but make sure you fill out a pink card
for the record now
please do
um and
just tell us your name and who you're
representing yeah and hi I'm a little
nervous
um my name is Michelle Roy and I am here
along with Wendy to represent the
population of people dealing with long
covid and other post-viral chronic
illnesses such as mecfs
which I have and I would like to state
that in regards to this particular study
this would have been hugely helpful for
me to stay in the workforce
I tried to stay in the workforce as long
as possible I had to leave my career and
keep stepping down and stepping down and
trying to find other work solutions that
I could continue to make a living
through
ultimately I reached out to a group
called the job accommodation Network who
sent me a group excuse me who sent me
literature on a a group of um
companies that were supposed to have uh
Pro disability
dogmas
one of those companies I ended up
applying to to see if I could benefit
from their
their
sorry I have cognitive enthusiasms as
witnessed if I could if I could benefit
from there
um
give me a minute from their programs
upon meeting
the people at a head
um they said hey we think you'd be great
for a position here we understand you
have limitations we would be happy to
work around them as we are a non-profit
who deals with getting and keeping
people with disabilities work
um a year in a year and two months in
I could no longer keep up cognitively
and sometimes physically
and so I was forced to resign if if this
study had been done years earlier I
believe that myself and millions of
other people who suffer from Lim from
limitating chronic illnesses could still
be in the workplace
I was also trying to work because as
Wendy mentioned
there is no buyer marker biomarkers
excuse me for for illnesses such as long
covid and mecf and other chronic
illnesses and so we are met with a lot
of
um speculation even though there are
other illnesses such as asthma and and I
believe Ms who also do not meet certain
biomarker accreditations but are not
given
um
the difficult
aspects to navigate that we are and so
I'm kind of apologize I'm kind of
getting off track right now but I for
one
know that I would still be
able to contribute financially
to the state of New Hampshire to the U.S
government to my own self
if a study like this were to take place
and so on behalf of everyone with
complex chronic issues that have been
met with the same challenges that I have
I ask you to please take this study into
serious consideration I would be very
happy to answer any questions and I I am
available at all times I live here in
Concord so I just ask you all please
to take this into
serious consideration
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much I appreciate are there
questions
I see oh representative Schultz hi I
just wanted to say I think you made your
points very clearly so thank you that
means a lot to me because a lot of times
things are fuzzy so I'm glad it came off
somewhat coherent thank you very much I
appreciate it thank you everyone for
your time seeing no questions I do not
have any other pink cards and make sure
you do get that one up here absolutely
um if there is no one else to speak on
on this bill
I would close the hearing for we have a
question from representative on this
paper
uh could the Department of Labor come up
to answer a question from the
representatives on this thank you
it's good to say good afternoon but it's
still a good morning thank you very much
Tracy McGraw from department of labor
legal unit
representative avaloni you have a
question thank you I do uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss McGraw
um
has the Department of Labor seen any of
these um
issues come before as a employment or
employer issue
I guess my first question to you if if
permissible would be what issues exactly
are you asking about whether or not
we've seen covet issues and people
having to be outside of work or having
to work remotely or whether we're
actually seeing
um discriminatory type issues
okay
um
we've all I think we've all been
affected in one way or another as far as
we started in 2020 where we were doing a
lot of remote work
and then in 2021 it went a little bit
more to trying to transition back into
the office work as far as obviously the
state is concerned most of us are in
office
a lot of private employers seem to be
dealing with
remote work and that seems to be working
to the best of my knowledge and I am
quantifying that as my knowledge uh
there does not seem to be a lot of
dispute right now between employers and
employees for those employers who have
to work from home whether it's because
of a covet exposure or because of a
concern with their own health and the
potential for a covet exposure so long
as it doesn't impact the actual job for
instance a lawyer in a law firm's
obviously got to attend hearings if it
is not possible for virtual hearings and
they are required to go in person and
they cannot
then obviously that can negatively
impact the job that they're required to
do
um my own knowledge I have not seen that
issue come into play where there hasn't
been
a way around it that an employer has
used as far as discrimination that I can
honestly say from my perspective I have
not seen that coming to the Department
of Labor at this time
other questions representative Cahill
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Brown
so especially in this tight labor market
isn't it likely that employers are going
to really Bend as far as they can when
someone in the sense I need an
accommodation of this type or that type
if they can do it
I think the last part of your phrase is
actually the most important part of the
phrase if they can do it
there are certain jobs that do require a
person to show up at the office or to
show up at another location such as the
legislature
um
I've seen that a lot of employers are
working more with employees to get them
to be to increase
the the number of employees that they
have but it really does come to the last
part of your statement if they can
representative Schultz you had a
question
are there other questions
seeing none and again I thank you very
much thank you very much
um I have no other request to testify if
you could also get a pink card to the
clerk I'd appreciate that thank you
um so I will close the hearing on HB 561
representative Broody if you could hand
up the other blue sheets I don't know if
we have any reports for the online
signups
all right so uh
uh yes please if you could get that for
the afternoon and and maybe we can
uh is it it's related to this
you know
is it a permitting test
s
ask let's talk about it afterwards okay
because we are a little behind
um
there's I believe there's a paper is
that the old one
uh is there a sign up sheet for 561
all right still working on it uh
hb410 does not have anyone signed up in
person
and while I'm waiting for the last sheet
I would like to remind the Republican
members of the committee the chairman
would like to hold a caucus a republican
caucus in this room
uh following when we in turn
and for HB 561 we had four people sign
up and uh
all four in favor
and we
do the pink cards also yeah
okay and with that uh
the hearing is recessed until one
o'clock when we will reconvene an
executive session
thank you everyone
foreign
so okay
calendar explaining
the majority the minority or in many of
these cases of the window but I will so
that's one thing to know if you're going
to make a motion you also have to be do
that we can all help you to do that is
it normal for people to have the itl
reasons like paragraphs pre-written or
you know it's very helpful to do that
okay yes that way you're not struggling
impairment
mic check one two
one two
hello yeah it's good restart the whole
system as well
microphone check one two to here on your
side okay
a mic check one two
microphone check ones okay
testifier mic one two
get prepared on their stuff
just this gentleman here
to go in the order which is
history okay
to the members of the labor committee uh
representative bogert is uh gonna be
sitting with us today uh representative
boy had some surgery so
we'll probably be back next week
so thank you for filling in
just going to work with a clerk here to
get you know the paperwork ready and
then we'll resume
bear with us is going to be a lot of
different votes and things today okay so
we're going to work our way through it
well
sir I think I don't know we'll be
okay
opening the executive session on House
Bill 48 FN
relative to employee protection covid-19
in the workplace
representative
no Granger
wow representative Prout no
it was told all right uh hold on we're
not ready I'm not ready yet that's okay
Brian I'm looking for yourself
I thought I had the sheet here
did you grab it back yeah is it but I
did yes
um
all right Mom sorry Mom
representative uh recognized for motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl
motion on the floor is itl do we have a
second on the motion I would like a
second
Granger seconds it
representative avaloni you're recognized
to speak to your motion thank you Mr
chairman uh as seeing as we're moving
past covid-19
um Protections in the workplace have
eased this would
um set us back a little bit thank you
thank you
are there any other representative
Sullivan
I I would second that that essentially
um I think these uh some of the covid uh
uh
reactions are um
things of the past I think we're ready
to move forward and um I think the
sponsor himself indicated that he was
not aware of any situations that this uh
bill would actually address so I think
it's a bill that's unneeded in past its
time thank you
are they are there any other
Representatives would like to speak
the motion on the floor is in expedient
to legislate has been seconded
we are now going to call the clerk would
you please call the roll
I don't work
Vice chair seaworth yes
rep avaloni yes
rep proud
yes rep love
yes
Brett bogert
yes I think it's did I mispronounce her
name
no you did good please correct me if I
do this is my first time doing this uh
rep Mason yes
Repco yes
reptrigo
yes
Ranger
yes rep Sullivan yes reparuti yes
rep Cahill yes repti Silvestro YES Prep
Susie
ripped Bouchard yes rep adjutant
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
Le clerk yeah
and the chair
yes
wow 20-0
objection to this bill being placed in
the consent agenda
seeing none thank you
yes
I just need to know who's writing the
consent
report the first person that makes a
motion is the one that writes the um
the floor of the blurb okay
we'll get it done I'll get it done since
I threw it at you
the next bill we're expecting today is
House Bill 57 FN I recognize
representative Granger for a motion
uh thank you Mr chair I would uh move
that we itl HB 57. motion of the floors
itl do we have a second on the motion
second
by representative avalani
uh thank you Mr chair uh low-wage labor
bands uh they price poor people out of
the market and have a tendency to hurt
people in uh economic times are tough
and most people are making above 15
hours dollars an hour nowadays anyway
thank you
looking for uh representative attitude
thank you Mr chairman
um today is a nice day outside so I'm
going to take a light scenic route to
get to my point today and he has my
permission to make it a polite Scenic
room
for the record my name is representative
adjective from Enfield uh my full name
is Joshua only adjutant my middle name
Ollie comes from my grandfather his name
was Ollie F Kenny Jr he died in 1998 so
I don't have any living memory of him
but through happenstance he and I share
one unique thing in common we are both
fans of the musical stylings of a
country singer named Roger Miller
most of Roger Miller's biggest hits came
out of the 1960s and they reflect that
time well
I've got about an hour commute down here
so I've often thrown on his greatest
hits album on the ride a lot of the
tracks like do Wackadoo are silly songs
that offer little if any historical lens
but there's probably his most famous
song King of the Road
that offers a glimpse into the past with
which I look at this bill before us here
today
the first verse is as follows trailer
for sale or rent rooms to let 50 cents
no phone no pool no pets I ain't got no
cigarettes
but two hours of pushing broom buys an 8
by 12 4-bit room
I'm a man of means by no means King of
the Road
this song was written in 1964 when the
minimum wage was a dollar and a quarter
an hour so Miller pushing a broom for
two hours at one time presumably at
minimum wage would make two dollars and
fifty cents before taxes assuming he
paid them
that two hours of minimum wage work in
1964 was enough to pay for his shelter
for five days the 50 Cent 4-bit room
let's compare that figure to today
a person who works two hours in a day at
minimum wage would make 14.50 before
taxes an average motel room just for
shelter runs over a hundred dollars a
night
forget two hours what about the whole
day fifty eight dollars a day before
taxes they aren't even halfway to
shelter and that's all their money
for a full month's work they're at 16 uh
at one thousand one hundred and sixty
dollars before taxes average rent in the
state of New Hampshire is almost two
thousand dollars again not even halfway
to shelter and all their money is gone
one of the big themes of the song King
of the Road is that Miller is a man who
only works when he is absolutely forced
to
he rides box cars he's a man of means by
no means even a person like that in 1964
had a minimum wage that ensured they
could survive
I can say today that our low-wage
workers here in New Hampshire do not
meet the description of Miller by any
means they are hard-working people who
through circumstances varying or working
low-wage jobs often multiple
I took the scenic route to get to this
point because in years past I've read
off the quotes from presidents who
invented the minimum wage and talked
about how it was meant to support a
decent standard of living and that to
this point has not changed a single mind
and I do not like recycling words
instead I would submit that this Society
once existed in a time where the minimum
wage may not have given everyone in the
world a perfect life but a livable one
I do not believe that 15 an hour on its
own is going to be enough indeed we do
need to tackle commodity prices and
markets like housing and Automobiles and
I submit that I don't support chasing
prices forever near the Setting Sun
but I think passing this bill to raise
the minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour is
a good start
I would ask the committee to reject the
itl motion before us and pass this bill
outright because to paraphrase Roger
Miller you can't roller skate in a
buffalo herd and you can't have a decent
living on 725 an hour thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman
I will vote against this itl motion uh
on 15 minimum wage bill because
according to the economic policy
Institute
80 000 workers in the first
congressional district and 73 000
workers in the second congressional
district will benefit from a fifteen
dollar minimum wage by 2025. yet
countless studies show that increases to
the minimum wage have not resulted in
massive job losses
though a 15 minimum wage is still not a
living wage it can help lift individuals
and families out of poverty establish a
degree of Economic Security for them and
reduce chronic anxiety and stress often
experienced due to income
insufficiencies
employers would benefit from lower
employee turnover and less money
spent for hiring and training
as a taxpayer I'm concerned that many of
these workers
that would benefit from this bill depend
on government safety net programs to
supplement their salaries to meet their
basic needs like food shelter
transportation and Heating
I urge all of my colleagues to join me
in not supporting
this itl motion on the 15 minimum wage
Bill thank you
I want to let other people speak first
before I uh calling you a second time
are there any other individuals like to
speak representative Schultz
I too am a big fan of Roger Miller I
think
it's a great thing to listen to so for
whatever that's worth but the other way
that um we're on the same page is an
article I just handed out uh to you all
um regarding it has a graph that
reflects the change adjusted for
inflation of since the minimum wage
began in October of 1938.
um
it is very difficult to feed your family
pay for gas afford transportation in
general
pay for our very exorbitant rents
um and that's an unemotional argument
it's just a fact
we are in all of New England
significantly lower than the minimum
wage in those States
we are the wealthiest state to default
to 7.25 cents an hour
and what that means is given the high
cost of living for heating assistance
for rents that keeps going up in a at a
high rate to get a loan to buy a home is
impossible
to afford the basics
you need approximately for a family
seventy thousand dollars according to
another article I happen to have
um from CNBC news
and
um
to be able to do the basics
means one very big point that I think is
a bipartisan one and that is our social
safety net in New Hampshire was never
meant to support workers
we were never supposed to use that as a
way to have wages paid for and
supplemented
in that manner workers
doing exactly what all of us I think
believe is what any able-bodied or able
person's ability to do that work should
be able to do
which is a Ford
just the basics that's all we're talking
here we're not talking frivolousness
we're not even talking student loans or
medical debt or you know saving for
retirement all the things that I would
personally say should be included
those are all still off the table never
mind
uh vacation if you even have the ability
to get paid
vacations at all we're just talking the
basics so why would the Live Free or Die
state
and we as lawmakers what under what
justification do we have to allow
workers to be paid so low
that they have to go on assistance
I have no problem whatsoever for those
that need it
because of illness or age or other
issues to be able to be on that social
safety net is what it's for
but workers
absolutely not
so when you hear that it would be a a
step higher to do the steps in the bill
which by the way we don't get to 15
right away it's in three steps
um
we still are lagging behind literally
every state in New England
and the states that default to 725
include States like Kentucky Mississippi
Alabama
states where it's still probably not
affordable for them either but far
easier to afford to live in States like
that I know that because I happen to
have grown up in one of those States
there's just much more affordable to
live in an area with the ability to to
pay rent at a better price and not have
to pay for heating assistance year round
so on that note
and with the interest of making sure
workers who are doing what we ask of
them
to work within our economy
and when employers aren't doing what
they should be doing paying folks a wage
that would not
lead to needing social safety net this
bill would
significantly improve that situation if
not completely fix it and um
I'll leave it at that Mr chair thank you
representative love
thank you Mr chair uh I will be voting
for The Ito and uh the reason being I've
got a close relative that uh that just
started at a a local coffee and donut
shop that's notorious for paying low
she started at 16 an hour a week and a
half later they bumped her up a buck
okay she has she's uh nine months into
recovery nine months ago she was a crack
addict with no work history for five
years okay we're not we're not talking a
real prize here when you look at her her
application her job application but they
hired her at 16. okay 16 an hour
um I I think this minimum wage is is
unnecessary for status
um and if the economy does go south and
uh and businesses start having a real
hard time they need the ability to to be
able to lay people off uh pay them at a
lower rate if they have to rather than
go out of business uh you know we'll be
we'll be jeopardizing the the uh the
existence of a lot of small business
businesses if the economy gets bad
enough
next
thank you
senator baroody thank you Mr chairman
um I think we'll find that people who
benefit from this increase in minimum
wage
um you're just going to pump that extra
money back into the economy
a rising tide lifts all boats it's going
back into everybody every business
person
every essential penny that they can
spend no clothes or whatever they won't
be out buying big steak dinners but they
might be able to go for coffee in the
morning
and um the states that were mentioned
before I think they're all Southern
States and they don't have the high
heating costs that we do
so increasing the minimum wage doesn't
mean that these people are going to go
out shopping around for banks to see
who's paying the highest interest rates
on your savings because they're not
going to be saving it they're going to
be spending it thank you
representative McKenzie
thank you Mr chairman I uh
I'm opposed to the Ito motion let me uh
give you reasons why
I have been in this room in rooms like
this for many years in testifying in
favor of increasing the minimum wage
but the reality is that it's not about
it's not about empirical evidence it's
not about what's what we can prove uh by
study after study after study
what this is about quite frankly and you
heard it in testimony from the industry
from some of the people in the
industries that are here
is we don't believe there should be a
minimum wage at all
that we don't believe that the that we
as a as a uh a state and as a government
who has an overall responsibility to
help people in the state of New
Hampshire we don't believe you have any
role at all in that and then it should
be according to the those people who
support
um keeping it where it is or eliminating
which we have done in New Hampshire is
that it should be based on free market
just let the market take care of things
well unfortunately the market doesn't
take care of things evenly and there are
many people quite frankly that don't do
well in the market for a whole lot of
reasons
and so I am going to vote against this
uh Ito because I think as a state
representative who comes from a large
community where we have a lot of people
that don't make a whole lot of money did
I have a responsibility to stand up here
and to say look there should be a flaw a
floor that that on that which nobody
drops below and that is a state
representative I have a responsibility a
moral responsibility to help set that
floor so that people don't fall uh
people live in the margins don't fall
into a place where they can't get out of
thank you Mr Jim
welcome
to I see no new hands oh Brian
representative Sullivan
thanks will
I'll just emphasize one piece that's
already been made and that is our
surrounding states they are all well on
their way towards a 15 minimum wage
it is an embarrassment for New Hampshire
to lag behind and say 725 is good enough
we ought to get with it tell our workers
that we value them
tell people who are considering moving
to New Hampshire that we value workers
and get on board with what the other New
England states are doing in moving
aggressively towards that 15 minimum
wage
again it's not going to take care of all
of their needs but it will provide a
floor like the representative just said
to support our workers let's let our
workers know that we value them
thank you
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair
I have heard it said that there's a
preference for letting the federal
government decide the minimum wage and
if they want to raise it that's then we
don't be disadvantaging uh New Hampshire
but our Market in the New England states
is is our Market that's that's where
we're competing for labor and we're
probably losing quite a bit just people
going over the Border
maybe they stay here because they don't
have to pay the other taxes but they
work over there and maybe they're
willing to pay that income tax even
heavens but uh I I think we need to
raise the wage thank you
thank you Mr chair
the economics behind raising the minimum
wage
to me is clear if we raise
the minimum wage and what we're paying
our employees the cost to sell Goods the
cost to sell labor the cost to make
things is going to increase with it
I don't know the single business that's
going to take it on the chin to say okay
I'm going to give you a pay raise but
I'm not going to increase my labor rate
so for every dollar that is increased in
labor on your service provider level
they're increasing your billable rate to
at least two dollars an hour so the cost
will continue to rise in my opinion we
will forever have a minimum wage that is
an unaffordable wage because we will
continue to price ourselves out of a
livable wage at a minimum wage wage rate
I believe it should be left to the
employers to decide what the best choice
is for their business model and I
personally do not like going to Home
Depot or any grocery store and having to
check myself out and by raising minimum
wages I fear that we are going to be
losing more and more jobs and our
unemployment will be affected greatly
thank you
who's ever
I'm going to be voting for itl basically
for the fact that if you watch the
business news that is where the real
News is located if you look at
McDonald's because of the wage increase
and and and the pressure being put upon
them the
um they have gone to automatic systems
robots and stuff so that now you'll have
robots serving you your McDonald's Happy
Meal
you don't have humans in those places if
you look at Home Depot and you look at
Lowe's they've already done away with
cashiers okay they were your last uh
hope of having some kind of employment
and even with that they were still
playing paying north of 15 an hour okay
so trying to continue to put pressure on
business and I have to agree with the
other representative that there is a
margin between what they're going to
sell and their cost of doing business so
every time you raise the cost of doing
business that's going to put the cost of
the product go into the end user to cost
more so if you looked at all those
relative statistics and you looked at
a gallon of milk and stuff you would
still see it would be outside the range
at Vista it's a local grocery store in
my hometown it's 4.99 a gallon already
okay and they have to sell it for that
to make up for the cost it takes them to
keep the operation running
people were not meant to buy a house on
minimum wage people were not meant to go
out and buy automobiles those were
starter jobs okay in the 90s we've
allowed all of our businesses to go
overseas now we're stuck in the service
industry and we don't know how to get
out of that unless we bring
manufacturing back so
this is the reason why I'm voting for
itl thank you
thank you representative drego
thank you for taking my statement I I
also too will be saying itl to this uh
and it's not it's not because of the
or the 1425 or even the 15 I think if it
was just one number
put out there it might have had a better
chance
um I don't like the variable
uh the rate at the end I call it a
variable
um minimum wage every January from 2026
on it resets off the cost of living
that does two things one it takes away
the power of a legislator ever to change
it again because it automatically
updates
um and two
it creates a huge issue for businesses
because every year they don't know what
the new minimum wage will be so the fact
that can always go up and never go down
creates a
one it's one way and two it also creates
a kind of a cluster at the end of the
year for new hiring
somebody got hired in December might be
one one rate and all of a sudden they're
getting grades because inflation is high
or cost of living is high
and uh it's just a very hard way to
especially if it's a business that has a
multi-year contract
now they're paying a higher rate for the
second year of the contract but they
can't go up on a contract so having a
variable minimum wage is to me is just
not not something that should be done
that's it
thank you representative see you
seaworth thank you Mr chairman about two
years ago I said something similar we
have some new people so I get to make my
joke again I have a really nice job here
the vice chairman I get to sit up here
and look really important but I I really
have no duties except for one in the
house rules the vice chairman is tasked
with looking at each bill and evaluating
it relative to the Constitution
and um
so I want to bring that up again since
it is my job
when I when I said this two years ago I
had just been looking at a bill that at
first it struck me as very odd it was a
wage related bill
that covered everybody but Exempted
counties and municipalities
and my first thought was probably what
some people here are thinking well
that's kind of hypocritical it's good
enough for to apply to all the Employers
in the state except the government
but the reason became clear to me when I
looked at the date on that bill it was
passed right after 28a was adopted by
the Constitution and at that time
legislators apparently were much more
serious about conforming to that
Constitutional Amendment
and the issue is the same if we raise
minimum wage
that will impose a cost on our towns and
our counties
and the Constitution requires
that we either pay for that cost
that we exempt them from that cost or
that we allow the citizens of each
subdivision a vote on that cost
so as it was my duty I felt I needed to
bring that up and so I did thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Vice chairman I
think everyone has spoken first who's
wanted to speak
so we're going to go in the second time
around just representative uh
representative Granger followed by
Cahill please
foreign thank you Mr chair uh it may
seem weird to hear a young person say
that they're passionate about not having
a minimum wage uh someone earlier uh
mentioned that uh some Republicans would
think that the proper minimum wage would
be zero I would be among them I think
that the minimum wage is a complete
travesty in the way that it completely
just throws young people under the bus
I'm not going to hold back any punches
by it I'm going to get straight to the
point I got out of high school in 2008
in New York
I had to work under the table I made
less than minimum wage that was the only
way I could get a job
everybody who said oh well the minimum
wage is helping him out it isn't it's
taking the bottom legs off the ladder
anybody who wants to get out of the pit
you're poor you're broke you can't get
out you can't earn 15 an hour you're not
worth 15 an hour that's what the minimum
wage does it doesn't say we're going to
give you a raise it only gives you a
raise if you were already worth 15 an
hour to that company if you're not worth
fifteen dollars an hour to that company
you don't get a job you get to work
under the table you get to not get money
you get to be broke and guess what
that's what happened to me that was my
childhood or when I first became an
adult when I got out and started getting
into the workplace that was how I got my
living that was how I made them do all
right I worked under the table at farms
wherever doing actual labor in order to
get ahead so everybody who tells me oh
well this is going to help the workers
no it isn't so I'd like to give a quote
by Thomas Soul about the history of the
minimum wage
in 1925 this is a quote from Thomas salt
quote start in 1925 a minimum wage law
was passed in the Canadian province of
British Columbia with the intent and
effect of pricing Japanese immigrants
out of the jobs in the lumbering
industry
a Harvard professor of that era referred
approvingly to Australia's minimum wage
law as a means to quote protect the
white Australian standard of living from
the invidious competition of the colored
races especially the Chinese who are
willing to work for Less
in South Africa during the era of
apartheid white labor unions urged that
a minimum wage law be applied to all
Races to keep black workers from taking
jobs away from White unionized workers
by working for less than the union pay
scale
some supporters of the First Federal
minimum wage law of the United States
the davis-bacon act of 1931 used the
exact same rationale citing the fact
that southern construction companies
using non-union black workers were able
to come north and underbid construction
companies using unionized white labor
end quote now the purpose of this quote
isn't to say that if you support a
minimum wage lawyer racist I do not want
to imply that in any way I know that the
people who are supporting this
legislation genuinely believe that they
are helping people out but the economic
principle still applies syntaxes exist
because we know that increasing the
price of a good results in less
consumption the point of increasing the
price of cigarettes is to decrease the
amount of people who smoke if you
increase the price of Labor that
naturally leads to less people hiring
now that may not sound like a big deal
when unemployment is as low as it is and
there's a there's a message desire for
workers but that's not going to be the
case forever the economy comes gets good
the economy gets bad eventually the
economy will be bad again and guess what
there's going to be a lot of really
broke teenagers who are looking for a
job in order to get out into the world
and they won't be able to get one
because we decided to pass minimum wage
law thank you
representative Cahill
yeah uh if the chair will allow I
actually have a question for the vice
chair
I'll allow it
Mr Vice chair uh could we in fact uh
finagle that restriction with the
Constitution by saying that the revenue
sharing that we do with the
municipalities covers this cost and so
many others
I suppose if the revenue sharing is
increased
to cover the costs you could say that I
I haven't done the math on it though
thank you
is there any further representative
thank you Mr chairman seeing as we do
Revenue sharing with cities we don't do
much revenue sharing with counties or
the state so how would that apply
I don't know I was
I don't know and I don't want to get
into it it was a nice play question by
representative KO so we're going to move
on to the people who want to uh speak a
second time representative
representative McKenzie uh thank you Mr
chairman and um I think the discussion
we've had here pretty clearly
um signifies where people are in terms
of what side you're on and uh again as
those who believe in it and those who
don't and here we are but that's not the
reason for my inquiry it relates to the
statement just made by my colleague on
the committee relative to the
Constitution
and I think to leave that uh on the
table uh is something that I think is
pretty dangerous to do
we have all kinds of things that come in
front of this committee that raise wages
that raise unemployment to raise workers
compensation that raise all kinds of
issues
um that could somebody could come in and
claim that the that the 28a limits us
from making those kinds of decisions now
I don't have the court information
firmly but I believe the courts have
ruled on that that in fact that's not
the case that we have the authority to
to make those kinds of those kinds of
decisions as a committee
and we can move forward with now we're
gonna we're gonna hear other legislation
in front of this committee that people
claim have costs of the communities and
therefore we can't do it so I I would
challenge that respectfully of my
colleague on this committee and I think
there should be some clarification
um relative to those kinds of things and
somebody has it's a constitutional
attorney or somebody from the state that
can inform this committee relative to
that discussion thank you
seeing no other hands
I will make my comments and we will have
the vote
I was taught something early on in my
career as a freshman legislator
that we should never
do anything that puts
um
an obligation onto another legislature
especially when it comes to finances
uh we make our own decisions uh in each
legislature has a chance to make its own
financial decisions so I have a problem
and I always have I've been consistent
with many years I have a problem with an
increase in the minimum wage based on
the Consumer Price Index
every legislature should make that
decision
I was up in Laconia yesterday and uh
I got a soda
and uh
um their advertisement for 17 an hour
on the way here this morning
they're advertising on
wgir am uh 35 an hour
for um
laborers and such at a Paving Company
they're already looking for people
um
so there there are New Hampshire has a
very good economy probably the best
economy uh in New England and the one of
the lowest lowest unemployment rates
and I and I like letting businesses make
the decision on what they're going to
pay
um and I think
they do a better job
the city of Manchester recently uh made
a decision both the school board and I
think the alderman had already done it
to increase the minimum wage for any
employee hired to 15 an hour which I'm
in favor of
because they made the decision they made
the decision as a as a board
um
the um lastly
the last session of Congress
had one party in charge of all three
branches of the Congress and all all
three branches not all three branches
but how's the Senate and the presidency
and when it came to raising the minimum
wage of 15 our Congressional Delegation
did not vote in favor of that
um so to ask us to to do something that
they wouldn't uh I find inconsistent
so I'll be voting no
um in favor of the bill even though a
lot of you know what my opinion is on
getting this monkey off the table off
the back and and doing
um the things that we should do as a
state but this is not the right bill
see there's no other comment
Madam Clerk
thank you Mr chair first of all our um
two Congressional representatives to the
U.S House of Representatives did vote
for uh 15 minimum wage it did not have a
vote in the U.S Senate
um for whatever that's worth
um I also though if folks are willing to
do an amendment to exclude the cola and
have a 13 minimum wage a 15 minimum wage
One Rate I
um as the prime sponsor
would welcome that and that's something
we could do we have not locked any view
in place yet on this bill
at this point I'm not entertaining any
uh amendments that are already prepared
um
there is a motion on the floor we've had
the discussion
I would have
um
appreciate if the clerk would call the
role thank you Mr chair
Vice chair seaworth oh and the motion is
on itl correct Vice chair seeworth yes
rep avaloni yes
rep Prout yes
prep love yes
bogerts yes
rep Mason yes
Repco yes
rep durago yes
rep Granger yes
ranking Dem Sullivan
no
rep baroody no
rep Cahill no
reptive Silvestro now
rep Susie
rep Bouchard no
rep adjutant
Brett McKenzie oh
the clerk votes no
replacer
and Mr chair yes
and 10 the most uh
the bills offer further motion
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chair
um I make a motion for ought to pass
motion on the floor is not too fast we
have a second second by uh
representative Schultz
the other floor the two
oh well representative
I could easily repeat myself because I
think all the reasons why I opposed itl
still work for odd to pass basically I
support increasing the minimum wage I
support this bill in the manner in which
it increases the minimum wage and I urge
everyone to vote ought to pass as I will
thank you
so you know other hands oh
representative never mind
all right
seeing no other hands to speak we have a
motion on the floor of ought to pass
it's been seconded clear Madam clerk
would please call the roll thank you
Vice chair seeworth no
we're at babyloni no
rep proud no
rep love
no
rep Boyd
oh no I'm sorry sir I did not correct it
on this sheet yeah we were perfect we'd
be annoying
um Brett bogert no
rep Mason no
Repco no
rep Drago no
rep Granger nope
ranking down Sullivan
yes
Rudy yes
rep Cahill yes
repti Silvestro yep
rep Susie
Brett Bouchard yes rep adjutant
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
replicaair yes yes and Mr chair
no okay same 10 to 10. okay
so that I will go to the floor with no
recommendation and
um and each side will provide me a
report
next hearing uh next executive session
House Bill 58 FN
a call on representative Schultz for a
motion okay thank you Mr chair I would
like to move on to pass with Amendment
and present the amendment first
um you should have a copy of it but I
did put together because I've heard a
bunch of questions
um let me hand this in
obviously that's not too many
3-070h is being moved
oh sorry um
uh representative Schultz has moved
Amendment
2023-00708 is there a second
second by representative Sullivan
representative uh recognized PQ uh
motion
so just as a blanket statement I'd like
to suggest that even if you're inclined
to not support the bill uh this makes
the bill better it simplifies the law
um so what I have passed around is an
additional copy of the amendment which
you probably already have it's very
simply worded if you'll see at the end
of line seven
it says subject to the following
exceptions colon
now the original bill would accept would
have eliminated all of the carve outs
that
um many of which are very popular I've
not I've since learned I've gotten a
lesson on skiing patrols and lots of
other things but if you turn to the
third page
you'll see this is the section of the
law that comes after the colon
and the existing bill this would all be
eliminated these are the carve outs
um like the ability for people to
essentially be volunteers ski patrol
folks and be given
um
ski passes I guess for the winter I
don't exactly know how that works
um I would love to learn to ski someday
but all of these sections
um would probably
rather than address them in the bill if
we did want to address any of them that
should come under a separate bill in the
future so just to improve the bill
as a bit of housekeeping I did not
um want to have the existing bill
eliminate the carve-outs
I hope that makes sense if not I can
take questions
representative Sullivan
foreign
yes I I will take responsibility for
asking for this amendment
um I didn't think it was proper to be
repealing a whole bunch of exceptions
without uh
really having people understanding that
that was happening and the way the bills
were drafted you'd look at the bill and
you could see that it was repealing the
sub minimum wage for tipped workers but
you couldn't see all the other stuff
that was being repealed and as rep
Schultz just said if there was an
interest in doing that it should be in a
separate bill with a separate hearing
giving anyone who had an interest in
those exceptions an opportunity to come
before this committee and testify either
in favor or against the repeal so I
believe this amendment gives us a much
cleaner bill
all it does is repeal the sub minimum
wage for tipped workers it does nothing
else and it's
um much easier to
contemplate I understand that some
people don't contemplate the same way I
do on it but um at least we're
it's not muddy anymore it's very clear
what we're trying to do thank you
it's not typical but since the amendment
um clarify clarify something and changes
something back to the original Law of
any quick questions or
thank you Mr chairman just to be clear
that it removes the first two paragraphs
of 279 colon 21 which deals with the
hourly rates for uh chipped employees
correct it leaves it in place I mean it
replaces it with the language in the
bill itself so the amendment would only
address
retaining those carve outs
the amendment itself doesn't
um change the intent of the bill which
was to address
tipped wage workers specifically
um without any unintended consequences
with the carve outs
does everyone understand what the carve
outs are
it's complicated there are certain carve
outs to the weights that have been made
over the years yeah okay Madness yes on
the second page
all right
so I'm sure everyone understands
sure
so we have an amendment of a motion
um it's been seconded there's been
discussion is there any further
discussion before I call the roll
representative
thank you Mr chairman section eight of
that uh
279 fall and 21 ultimate records for
sure
I found um
no that's not what that means
one more time section eight those
employees covered by the introductory
paragraph
second States for Halloween
so making sure the best can be changed
as well as what the changes in the
humanity
well the introductory as the amendment
is written the introductory paragraph
isn't touched by the amendment but the
bill itself would be different
so as it refers to the introductory
paragraph which in the law itself is
um has no additional Roman numerals like
this one does it would apply that change
so the original Bill does change the
introductory paragraph I think that was
a very complicated way of agreeing with
you
sorry
follow up I would that be handled with
overtime the state's overtime for those
particular work that invest in another
law with another bill
I believe the existing law on overtime
laws
um would still apply I don't I can look
it up we could look it up I don't
believe the initial paragraph on
279 colon 21 addresses that
but let's look it up I realize you're a
restaurant owner and probably have it
memorized
yeah let me look it up when I answer his
question correctly
or a person from the labor department at
Indiana
sorry guys can I see what you're doing
now
what's in here if we have the books it's
over there 279 Colin 21 is over there
any aspect of the existing law that
addresses
so the bill itself doesn't change that
just see what I'm talking about
the existing it as my reading of it and
I don't know if this is something our
committee assistant could help with but
in my reading of the existing law and
the bill itself
I do not see any additional reference to
overtime in that regard
um so I assume that's under a different
part of the law or continues it with
those carve outs including that section
that you've read so as far as I can tell
that doesn't change it at all
I'm not a lawyer
if I if I might read this the
Roman numeral eight of 279.22
those employees covered by the
introductory paragraph of this section
with the following exceptions so in
addition to the regular compensation
that's a different part of the law
well
sorry a section 22 is not addressed in
the bill or the amendment other than if
any references to it or existing in the
text but it does not change
the the subsequent sections of the law
it only addresses 279 colon 21. right
which is what I'm reading representative
so so if I'm looking at 279 21 sorry
Roman 8
okay okay yeah
it's not gonna work through this sure
7121 Roman 8.
okay
so how does this not affect
this
sentence here
well I will say I did go over this
um not from a policy discussion but just
um in a discussion regarding how the
Department of Labor here in New
Hampshire views it I don't know if I
should say Rudy's name but he and I went
line by line of these carve outs and as
far as I understand it
um those sections would remain and not
go away with the amendment so
um given that the introductory paragraph
would change
but the carve outs including the text
you just referenced would not be
eliminated in this amendment with this
amendment
the intent of the bill Still Remains and
it doesn't make any major changes in
that sense
is anyone from the Department of Labor
possibly here
representative Sullivan
I just called up the law and essentially
the portion of the introductory
paragraph that's been removed is a part
that deals with tipped workers
um so basically Section 8 simply says
that if you're making the minimum wage
you'll get time and a half for over 40
hours I think I believe it still works
cleanly and effectively but we simply no
longer have a tip to minimum wage so I
don't believe there's a conflict
and I will say Mr chair that matches I
can't speak for the Department of Labor
but I did go line by line in great
detail
um
we could
just leave it okay
I was going to make sure that I'm
representing to everybody here what
um so
um I need to read this if you on a Brian
if you wouldn't mind um
if there's any other questions
I seen
I read this
no do you want to just
thank you Mr chairman um also a Section
8 also has a and N A one if it does not
operate for more than seven months in a
calendar year so if it was a
anything that didn't operate on a
seasonal basis would that would they
still be forced to pay a minimum wage
representative Sullivan
um you and I uh discussed prior to that
we would accept the motion
I think we're all
um realistic here that the motion
um will on this bill excuse me the final
tally vote on this bill will be
consistent with the previous bill
I am unsure
whether this amendment does what
initially requested
um
it
airing the side of caution I would
rather
vote in the bill as is you still have
the ability since it's going to be a
um no recommendation of the floor to
bring forth an amendment
but I'm what you and I discuss and what
this would do I am
I am unsure that it's going to do that
and not conflict with the other things
I'd like your I guess I don't share your
um
lack of Surety because looking at it as
I said a minute ago it carves out the
chunk of the opening paragraph that
deals with sub minimum wage it leaves
intact the part of this opening
paragraph that marries our New
Hampshire's minimum wage to the federal
minimum wage in all aspects of these
provisions on the third page remain in
place and they seem to work just fine
with the
federal minimum wage is New Hampshire's
minimum wage I don't see a conflict
representative seaworth
would appreciate if you would share what
you whispered to me all right
here don't don't whisper things to the
chairman he makes you share them with
the class don't don't see that my issue
with this is that the the old
introductory paragraph talked about tip
workers exclusively and chapter what
uh okay
for an executive session but we have to
everyone needs to make sure before they
vote on this that we're on the same that
everyone understands it all right all
right so I won't say the word
exclusively again I'm quickly reading it
looks like the first paragraph of 279 21
talks about tip workers
Section 8 says if you are covered in
that first paragraph
and you work more than 40 hours a week
you get time and a half for it
which means if so if you are getting the
327 an hour which is specified in the
second paragraph
but you do you work more than 40 hours
an hour 40 hours a week those additional
hours would be
uh now hard math whatever 3 27 times
time and a half is or something so we're
going to change if we adopt this
amendment that first paragraph
he'll refer to home workers in which
case eight says those employees covered
which is everybody get time and a half
pay once they go over 40. and
what I was whispering to the chairman is
I do agree that that doesn't sound like
that's the way I read it but that
doesn't sound like the way this
amendment has been represented
thank you
may I try again
yes thank you yep thank you Mr chairman
this is I appreciate your
allowing us to clarify
I'm looking at the current law 279.21
first sentence unless otherwise provided
by Statute no person firm or Corporation
shall employ any employee at an hourly
rate lower than that set forth in the
federal minimum wage as amended
period
the next sentence starts with tipped
employees
everything from that
sentence starting with tipped employees
to the end of the opening paragraph is
repealed by both the original Bill and
this amendment so basically
as amended
as proposed everything on that second
page would apply to those people earning
the minimum wage just the folks in that
first sentence
so basically it says that if you work
more than 40 hours a week you get time
and a half that's one and a half times
seven twenty five an hour
it works
um so I don't think there's a problem
here
um
we've simply take carved out the tipped
minimum wage from the minimum wage
itself so basically everybody including
the tip workers are in at least 725 an
hour plus tips
um
it's clear to me I hope it's clear to
others
representing
thank you Mr chairman just for
clarification are we talking about the
first paragraph or the second paragraph
because the second paragraph also
references
the first paragraph because the first
paragraph is the one referenced
um
I don't even know where what are you
talking about with the second paragraph
it's too bad
follow-up Mr chairman yes yes
um
the following exceptions unless
otherwise otherwise but otherwise
provided by Statute no question form
um and then it defines tipped employees
under 178 colon 20. are you removing
that paragraph as well
yeah the whole thing is removed yes but
there's two separate paragraphs in that
yes but
the whole thing is removed the only
thing this does is put back in the
exclusions correct
because it's reading this it's just by
the following exceptions but the colon
it still provides for tipped employees
wherever that's all removed
um line seven
yeah fourth and the federal minimum wage
laws as amended subject to the following
exceptions colon gives you a second
paragraph um it starts with unless
otherwise provided
so I'm not sure that that is that comes
at the end of the second paragraph It's
also at the end of the first paragraph
okay you're right
I'm just want to make sure that we're
deleting the entire first paragraph and
second paragraph that is correct that's
what it does
Mr chair and I would like to add that
that is what the bill does
so in terms of the amendment itself
we're just keeping the carve outs in
place and that's the existing law
already so
um the amendment really is about
keeping in a part of the law that people
feel is already working or not a part of
the discussion and the intent of the
original bill so what you're citing is
already
um the law
didn't realize
okay is everyone completely confused or
are you all following along here
okay
representative
I will not be supporting this
thank you
as it is I'm clear
are there any other
representative McKenzie uh I realized
it's a 208 but the labor department is
10 minutes away from here
I would think that we could probably get
Rudy over here somebody from the
Department over here to make sure we all
understand what it is we're voting on uh
so it's clear uh so I I would make that
suggestion perhaps
are we allowed to uh break in the middle
of an executive session yes
the chairman wants to race us
I think you could recess this and move
on to the other ones and then
I'm going to uh
do the following I'm going to recess
um
the executive session on House Bill 58
I'm going to call see if I can get
someone and the vice chairman is going
to resume with the next bill on House
Bill 74. and you will not call a vote
until I return sir
emotions
so I'm going to
open the executive session on how spill
74.
and I would like Mr chairman yes may
movement Amendment
um
I didn't record
I was going I want to recognize
representative avaloni for a motion
let's see and uh
I expect there will be
a point where the amendment can be moved
I would hope so
if if not now then later but I thought
now was an excellent time to do it
I appreciate that
representative Abalone thank you Mr
chairman I move Ito
that has been moved in second
representative avalani is
recognized to speak on his motion thank
you Mr chairman um as was heard through
the testimony
um we're changing
um
definition of
wages due to earn time vacation time and
paid time off shall be considered
compensation
um I think that that is left up to the
employer and employee to determine
um
moving forward I think that would be the
Best Way Forward on part of this the
other part of this the
department has already said that it's
hard to go after the former owner or
unclaimed wages as that they have been
dissolved I think that this bill
well well-intentioned and everything
else is
um unworkable thank you Mr chairman
uh representative prouts
um thank you Mr chairman in addition to
the previous estate concerns which I I
Echo and agree with I also have concerns
that this bill is effective 60 days
after it is signed into law which
essentially would be retroactive as
viewed to any vacation time that an
employee has in the bank at that time
and I have very concerned a lot of
concerns about changing the rules on
time that's already in the bank with
employers
much more so than changing the rules for
vacation time earned after a change I
have a lot of concern about just pulling
the rug on different businesses and
saying previously that was not a you
know liability you hit list had to list
on your balance sheet because you didn't
have to pay it out according to law but
all of a sudden you know somebody may
have had a month of vacation time banked
and new rules on that that bank not just
the new time earned so I'll be voting
for the itl motion for that reason in
addition
thank you
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair uh let me just
counter some of the statements
previously made
most recently the statement about the
retroactive well it might be it might be
a concern although one thinks that the
employer has every intention of having
the vacation taken and and paid for
during the course of employment so it
shouldn't really be an unrecognized and
unanticipated atom on the balance sheet
the vacation is offered with the intent
that it will be used
uh as for the
other concern
if we passed if we were to pass this law
then businesses would be on notice that
when they are selling they would not be
closing up and screwing off until they
had native arrangements to transfer the
out the vacation hours or pay the
employee that's the purpose of the law
thank you
did I see another hand down
yeah representative Sullivan
simply put I'm going to be voting no on
the itl because I'm dying to see the
amendment that's forthcoming
representative Granger
I think Mr Mr chairs yes um so my I'm
going to be in favor of the itl um I
believe it's unethical for legislators
to interfere with private contracts
there's a lot of companies in New
Hampshire who don't have a regular PTO
system that this bill is kind of aiming
at and uh if it is a private contract
and it doesn't work in the one size fits
all fashion that this bill sort of cuts
out then uh it's really going to change
the dynamic in a lot of workplaces and
have very broad reaching effects across
a wide variety of industries that we
cannot foresee so we already enforce
labor contracts as agreed to so there's
really no point um if if there is a if
there's a company that's not abiding by
their labor contract that's already
enforced we don't need to change
anything
foreign
other members
continue
you continue we
if there is no one else who wishes to
speak at the time at this time I would
ask the clerk to call the roll
okay the motion is Ito
and expedient to legislate
Vice chair seeworth yes
rep bavalani yeah
rep Prout YES Prep love yes rep bogert
yes
rep Mason yes rep Cole come yes
rep Drago yes rep Granger yes
ranking member Sullivan no
reprodi no
rep Cahill no rep D Silvestro
rep Susie
Brett Bouchard no
rep adjectives
Rhett McKenzie
the clerk votes no
replicaair no
Mr chair yes
shocking
road is tied it's open for other
kale
thank you Mr chair uh I would like to
move on to pass and introduce
uh Amendment
20230378h
and speak to the amendment just a moment
please
tell a second
so the motion on the floor is ought to
uh excuse me introducing Amendment
2023-03788 it's been moved Cahill
seconded by Sullivan
the other floor thank you Mr chair
uh
the amendment is is uh narrowing the the
original Bill quite a bit and now we're
not covering the people who leave a job
uh on good terms uh perhaps you know
they could have any number of reasons
reasons for leaving but they they under
this with this amendment they will leave
behind in the unused vacation if that's
the policy of the employer for many
Employers in the state that is not the
policy and they would pay out what is
earned in fact earned vacation time
however we're not going to do that here
what we what we removed that section and
now we are only going to insist that the
workers unused and on your earned and
unused time be paid
upon termination when the result when
this is the result of the layoff when no
return date has been set
and uh
when each one is a change of ownership
and the the business will then either
transfer the uh unused time to the new
employer
or pay the employee
this is something that we have that's
been identified by several people as
reasonable that's the right thing to do
these are the described by someone
familiar to this committee as being
egregious events that shouldn't happen
in this state and yet they do if we do
not pass this amendment and this bill
this happens it's reported to the labor
department you know and if it happens to
someone else after we've had this
opportunity to look at this bill it will
be on us
uh
I mean I when I when my wife and I first
became involved with the making strides
Against Breast Cancer they had the
slogan you or someone you know
and certainly that applies we have no
idea when cancer is coming we have no
idea when the layoff is coming uh the
employer will not usually tell you when
he's going to sell the business or that
you will lose your time
these are events that are unplanned but
beyond the control of the employee and
they should not forfeit the time that
they have earned it should be
transferred in the event of a sale in
the business or they should be paid
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative Cahill
representative avalani
thank you Mr chairman and I thank the
representative for the clarification on
the amendment
um
line six and seven
um what if the employee goes back to
work after 12 weeks
for some of the seasonals
things only work seven months or even
some of them even six months and they
want to hold their
vacation time or in time to when they
come back or when they want to build it
up to the company or maybe they going
from seasonal employee to a permanent
employee I mean could they
how does that work with them
thank you representative uh
the 11 weeks was chosen because that's
the number that the Department of
Employment Security uses to say that if
you if you're not due back at work with
11 weeks but I think in the real world
in the real world there would be an
understanding uh that you yes it will
not it's not necessarily a certain date
it's not April 2nd
uh or the third Monday in in June it's
you know when conditions and and it's a
day the target date so that is there's
an understanding between the employer
and the employee that yes you'll be
coming back to work if that doesn't
happen and only if that doesn't happen
would the employee be contacting the
labor department to say this was not the
plan and I would like to receive my
earned but unused vacation pay
lower yes
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative
um why wouldn't they contact the
employer if they were
expecting to be out longer than the 11
weeks
thank you thank you for the
clarification what I mean is when you
are laid off from a Paving Company or or
Etc
and they say well we expect you back
when this happens or this time this
month you know in this period and and
we're not gonna you have the option of
uh
if you agree that that's what's going to
happen we're not going to pay you a
vacation it's a
who hold on to it and continue to when
you resume work you'll have that
vacation time for use
but if it doesn't happen
if the employer doesn't call you back
and you you reach out to them and they
say well we're not going we're not going
to be able to hire you back something
else is going on this is when you would
say to them well we had an agreement and
I can go to the labor department and
have this adjudicated
area of the mode we're
um we are just so you know
um we no no we have no time concerns and
Rudy Ogden will be here in about 10 or
15 minutes so just
we're just gonna go the same Pace we're
going thank you um so that that would
become a layoff with no return date so
that would follow under the first
sentence five and six
and that would be there would be do
their wages due at the end of that
following week that they're apprised of
their permanent layoff or
their separation because of non does not
work right thank you if they if they do
not return to work as anticipated then
the wages then the earned vacation would
be due
and I I also ran this by
of the department and it is workable
they understand it it's workable from
the Department's perspective
any other questions on the amendment or
comments on the amendment
representative Sullivan followed by
avaloni
I support the amendment
um I also support the hard work that
representative Cahill has put in in
trying to come up with a formulation
here that is more palatable and um
I I just uh I think he's he's bent over
backwards to try to find something that
would work that would uh provide some um
Equity to uh
um workers who have uh their vacation
snatched up from under them by no fault
of their own and he's continuously tried
to uh adjust and amend
um to make this work and I hope we can
get there on at least on this amendment
thank you
thank you um again back to line six and
seven that we're requiring employees and
employer and employee agrees in writing
that the employer pulled the payment
pending the earlier of their return or
to work or 11 weeks so now we're
requiring another mandate on employers
to have all of these agreements in place
in case they do come back to work or
don't come back to work do we know how
many employers or employees and how much
work that's going to cost each business
thank you Mr adolani uh
there is already a requirement that for
those who have vacation accrued that
when they when the employee borrows a
few days or a week and then leaves the
company
if the employer hasn't asked them to
sign an agreement that they that amount
will be reduced from their final check
the employer the employer can't recoup
that money so it's
it's really just another sort of
protective you're you're sure you're by
by agreeing that you want the person
back
and saying I yeah this is I'm serious I
want you to come back I don't want you
to go and get another job and leave here
I want you to come back your vacation
will be waiting for you
uh you're kind of helping your retention
rate
it's it's you know an understanding
between the employer and employee which
we think should be a good relationship
if for some reason things change then
the employee the employee does not
forfeit that which he has earned he it
can be he can reclaim it
that's what I'm trying to get to with
this and I guess the temporary and the
seasonal was yet another complication uh
and I think we agree that when when you
don't quit the job you don't uh set the
place on fire punch the boss and then I
was uh even give notice and train your
new help uh well at this point if it's
not beyond your control you really
should get what you earned and they
should be viewed as wages
not in other states nearby they have
none of these technicalities you just
get what you had on the books regardless
if you did punch the Boston in those
which I don't recommend no
I apologize
well thank you uh thank you for that
elaboration the the question I have is
does every employer have to get that in
writing from every employee even though
they are due back work because this is
mandating a written policy
for each employee to sign that the
employer can hold on to there
vacation okay so it's going to be
another layer of HR work to enforce this
to make sure that the employee can't go
to the labor department in eight weeks
and say hey I didn't get my
I didn't get my vacation pay even though
it says it in the law but I signed a
paper and they they forced me to sign a
paper but I'm back to work next week
so I'm kind of just want to make sure
that we're
taking care of the business as well as
taking care of the employees
thank you Mr avaland I I assure your
concern uh this is intended for those
seasonal temporary situations which we
know are frequent and and it really is
not a a terribly arduous layer of just
we had the we had the employer sign the
employee handbook we have the employee
uh sign all manner of things when
something changes and this is
anticipated they know that they're going
to stop Paving or whatever it is they're
doing construction wise when weather
conditions uh prohibited so it's it's
not really uh it's not really a brand
new thing it's just a way of documenting
what was the plan
and it gives the opportunity for the
employee to recoup if the plan falls
through
Mr chairman thank you
all right seeing there's no other hands
I'm just going to ask you folks for a
minute or two
um
the clerk is out with Rudy Ogden
explaining it so he can read it and
while we're finishing up the business on
this one
but I can't call the roll because she's
not here
it is time for a bathroom break
or water break please come back as soon
as possible
but the but the gallery you have to stay
you cannot go to the bathroom
it doesn't take out it only takes out
from here down
it says
amend the bill by a replacement question
correct one state oh yeah yeah it makes
it better here
um
so you're right but what you're saying
is you thought this replacement yeah no
it just replaces five a can I ask on
that one second yes
foreign
uh thank you Mr chairman before we move
on if you have any questions on the
amendment uh Mr Ogden is in the house uh
this is Mr Juve
well
um
this one I don't think is a policy
there's a there's a policy thing not so
much a understanding of the amendment uh
I believe uh representative there's two
other uh questions representative
abalani followed by representative Prout
okay experiment uh thank you again
representative Cahill
um just so I'm clear
um this is not replacing the original
bill it's only repricing section VA it's
redefining VA under paragraph two it's
not removing the first part of your
original bill that is correct so the
fresh by the original bill will stay
part of the bill yes thank you
representative probe
um thank you uh representative Cahill
how would this work if this
um you know again regarding effective
date and how the transition Works how
would this work if when this became
effective If This Were to pass and
become effective someone was in the
middle of a layoff waiting there uh you
know return to work 10 weeks out would
it would if they had previously agreed
the navigation be time be held over
whether that then all of a sudden be a
requirement to pay it out on the spot I
mean how would it work if it just became
an effective while the business was in
the middle of this temporary layoff
thank you Mr Pratt that's an interesting
question and I think
I think if the employer and employee did
not work it out themselves they could
certainly contact the New Hampshire
Department of Labor who would be able to
answer that question
they would whether no with the if the
law had taken effect if that was if that
was for the situation we're at the
midpoint they would know how to
interpret that that's above my pay grade
so we don't know right now uh what the
Department of Labor would say to
somebody they contact in that situation
uh we might we might ask someone from
the Department of Labor who's here if
he'd like to care if he'd care to
extrapolate on what may happen if this
happened and that happened and it wasn't
raining on a Tuesday in November
thank you
I didn't think my day was going to be
like this
well
it's all right are there any other
questions about the amendments
foreign
we have to wait
I apologize
um we need
everyone in the room do we know where
hmm
keep going
yes
this is just to adopt the amendment
Amendment just adopt the amendment
it's
okay if you want so this is yeah so the
motion is to adopt the amendment the
clerk will call the role if you're in
favor yes if you're against nay and
that's Amendment 378.
Vice chair seeworth no
Brett babalani
rep Prout no prep love no rap Bogart
no
rep Mason oh Repco no prep Draco no prep
Granger nope
ranking member Sullivan yes
rapper Rudy yes rep Cahill yes repti
Silvestro yes repsusi
rep Bouchard yes rep adjutant
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
Brett LeClaire yeah Mr chair no
shopping 10 to 10.
thank you Mr chair
um I would like to move ought to pass on
the bill
um as it was originally presented
motion on the floor is odd to pass a
Sullivan second by
representative Cahill
I was hoping for discussion we have the
foreign
I think we beat it to death
I think rep Cahill made every effort to
uh accommodate some concerns
um
apparently he did not hit the mark
however I still believe it's a good bill
um we've been working for a long time to
try to preserve the earn time for people
who by no fault of their own have lost
employment and also lost that earned
time
um so I I believe I believed it was a
good bill to start with I believe rep
Cahill worked hard to try to make it
more palatable as I said but I will
still vote in favor of what I believe
was a good bill from the start thank you
thank you
representative kale
thank you Mr chair uh indeed it was a
good bill uh the amendment does improve
it and if we end up with a 10 10 I will
certainly bring the floor Amendment to
the floor where I believe it will pass
because there are people
in the larger body who will support this
it's been done before
and I believe it will happen again thank
you Mr chair
you're welcome
are there any other kind any other
comments
No Doubt uh representative Sullivan that
representative KL has worked very hard
for a number of years
and one of the the issues
is that
representative
the issues is that the concerning of a
vacation time and some of these other
things that are offered to employees
um
they are perks there are benefits to
keep employees happier to to we could do
we want them to be rested we don't want
them to come in and when they're sick
all these different things are decisions
that employers make
and and the issue I've always had from
the beginning is at a certain point it
has to it has to be cash on the
barrelhead and that's not necessarily
what business owners think of that there
are situations where businesses earn two
weeks pay people have waited you know
two weeks vacation time they've waited
till the second of January and they quit
and they say you know
maybe two weeks and
and putting this into wages where they
have to be presented in or pay within a
week
um I just
I would
businesses need to be able to have the
decision
um to
present what they want in their employee
manual I had an employee that I hired
from another
employer years ago
and he refused to pay her
the remaining week in her vacation pay
and she was upset about it she showed me
the employee manual I accompanied her to
the Department of Labor hearing
and she won
and rightly so
because
there was nothing in the employee manual
to say otherwise
and um
inserting something where it has to be
wages and has to be paid in the barrel
head for any number of potential reasons
that would happen is just too much for
me but no doubt
representative Cahill
um you you know my admiration for you
especially on this this bill I'm just
sorry I can't
um
it's not where I I would like it to be
at this point
seeing no other comments
um
metal clerk please call the role of
motion on the floor is
ought to pass
Vice chair seaworth no
rep abalone
rep Prout no crap love no all right
bogert
no
Brett Mason no Brett Holcomb no
rep Drago no rep Granger nope
ranking member Sullivan yes
baroody yes rep K Hill yes rep D
Sylvester yeah rap Susie
rep Bouchard yes RIP adjectives
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
replica yes Mr chair
no
10 to 10. all right all right we're
consistent or with no recommendation
I'm going to reconvene the executive
session on House Bill 58 FN
we're discussing
Amendment brought in by representative
Schultz and I would like to call
assistant Commissioner Rudy Ogden from
the Department of Labor to shed some
light on the
uh
confusion that
the different opinions of what the the
amendment may or may not do you've had
an opportunity to look at the amendment
I have nice
um would you like to make a statement on
just the amendment uh I understand
you're not making a policy uh comments
um or what would you like to hear
questions of from the
from the committee so I would start uh
just uh for the record Rudy Ogden Deputy
Commissioner Department of Labor I had
had conversations with representative
Schultz relative to her Amendment my
understanding is the intent of what she
was trying to do was hone in on uh
removing the concept of sub minimum for
tipped employees and what we had then
talked about was the fact that in
addition to a sub minimum for tipped
employees if you look at the language of
RSA 279 21 what it does is it says okay
there's going to be uh this idea that
people are going to be paid at least the
federal minimum wage it then carves out
a category and says directly tipped
employees will be able to be paid a sub
minimum wage and then it says that and
in addition to that there's a whole host
of folks who are again not subject to
the limitations again they are not
necessarily having to be paid a minimum
wage such as caddies uh ski patrolman
things of that nature my understanding
of what this amendment would do upon
review of it is that it's leaving those
subsidiary exceptions in it's taking out
in the introductory paragraph the
reference to tipped employees so it's
saying everyone's going to be paid the
minimum wage is set forth by federal
standard and then it says there are
those certain exceptions with the colon
and then that list remains I would
highlight the fact that there is a than
a secondary if you look for in the
existing language and apologies that I
pull it up on my phone but if you look
at the existing language of Statute I
guess some confusion didn't come up
relative to seasonal employees and
things of that nature what that's saying
is it's saying that there are employees
uh who if they're covered by the
introductory paragraph So basically
everybody but the exceptions like
caddies and newspaper uh salesmen things
of that nature that if they work over 40
hours they're entitled to an overtime
premium that's what that language is
doing I'm happy to take questions if
there's specific uh questions on that
but I want to be clear that this
amendment would not impact who is is
subject to or entitled to the overtime
premium I don't believe that the way
that this is framed would alter or
affect that
so I'm happy to take any questions
thank you Mr chairman good to see you
again uh commissioner Ogden
um
the question that I have is
on line seven it says subject to the
following exceptions except under 279
colon 21 there's two paragraphs that say
the same thing
subject to the following exceptions and
then subject to the following exceptions
so which paragraph is it removing or is
removing bolts
I would believe
it's removing both in the sense of the
reason there's those two paragraphs now
is last session or perhaps it may have
been two sessions ago there was an
amendment which said if there's an uh
change at the federal level because
remember New Hampshire doesn't have its
only its own explicitly stated minimum
wage we tracked to the FED minimum wage
so a couple uh
sessions ago they had put in this idea
that if the federal minimum wage changes
that the sub minimum rate would not
track to that it would have said cap at
327. that does not take effect though
unless and until the federal minimum
wage changes
I believe that this amendment as
presented would essentially replace both
of those paragraphs because there would
not then be a sub minimum wage for
tipped employees if that makes sense I
don't know if I'm being clear but again
my understanding of the reason there's
those two paragraphs is one comes into
play saying that if the feds change
their minimum wage the state will still
have its sub minimum rate capped at 327.
this is removing the idea or concept of
sub minimum for tipped employees so both
paragraphs go away and then what you're
then left with is just an introductory
paragraph that says everyone's getting
paid the federal minimum wage subject to
the following exceptions this amendment
doesn't change any of those existing
exceptions
yes
while you're thinking I'm going to call
and look at the clerk or representative
Schultz thank you actually I was gonna I
know that
um
representative avaloni had a question
about in this section that would remain
with the amendment
um
the section addressing overtime so
that's section eight
under
the existing you know you have your
carve outs and then you have a
description about overtime
and if that would
be
to go into effect now for tip wage
workers
my impression is that already is the law
is that true yes that's true correct
that the the language in in Section 8 is
saying that those folks covered by the
introductory paragraph under existing
law or under this amendment they would
also be entitled to an overtime premium
so again the Department's reading of
this amendment is that that would not be
a change under this proposed legislation
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman and just because I am confused
Section 8 applies to currently all
hourly employees so the the language of
Section 8 is saying anyone who is
covered under the initial paragraph is
entitled to this so yes it would
typically be your hourly employees it'd
be basically anybody who's working if
you look at the language of 279 21 now
it's saying if you're working uh you're
entitled to at least federal minimum
wage for All Hours worked
subject to the following exceptions and
then this Section 8 says if you're
covered by that introductory paragraph
and you're not subject to those
exceptions then for any hour over 40
you're entitled to the overtime premium
excuse me
uh representative bogert followed by
avaloni
thank you Mr chairman
so if I understand this correctly uh the
New Hampshire minimum wage would
disappear and the federal minimum wage
would take precedence and if that's so
then would that also have an adverse
effect on the uh
tipped wage earners because now they're
making minimum wage and they wouldn't
necessarily need to be tipped
so present laws that there is not a New
Hampshire minimum wage New Hampshire for
purposes of minimum wage law says that
we track to the federal whatever the
feds establishes the minimum wage that's
what we're tracking to so this that's
existing law and that would be the law
under this amendment
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you again commissioner
Ogden
um
so there's a classification of
employment according to the iOS for
chipped employees which requires a sub
minimum wage
this would reclassify those employees as
hourly employment
I don't
I don't think that the IRS there's a
nationally compulsion that people
classify and employ a sub minimum or
tipped I think instead how it works is
that you are as an employer entitled in
certain instances to pay someone who
could be deemed a tipped employee less
than minimum wage so I don't again and
I'm not an IRS expert but I I do not
believe that it's a matter of the IRS
saying those are tipped employees and
have to be paid less you would always be
entitled to pay them more it's just in
certain instances you are entitled to
pay them less than minimum wage provided
that they meet the standard set forth in
federal law or in this case state law
oh hold on the New Hampshire doesn't
have an income tax
so there'd be no mechanism for an hourly
employer for an hourly employee to
retain wages
or to claim wages above their hourly
employment
would that be correct I'm not sure I'm
understanding the question I apologize
a tipped employee makes 327 an hour
they're made employers and employees are
incredibly mandated to require
withholding of wages which is their
tipped employee the tip wages were
required to
report them
if we no longer for hourly employees you
no longer have that ability to withhold
weight withhold tips because technically
they're no longer a tipped employee
they're now an hourly employee
so with the Department of Labor we
classify that and change the definition
of 178 colon 20-a which defines tipped
employees
without trying to make I believe that
they're both tipped and hourly and what
I mean by that is even under existing
law someone who works as a server
they're being paid an hourly rate
and if they get 30 or more of tips for a
month directly from customers under our
law they could also be deemed a tipped
employee so they're both hourly in tip
so I'm not necessarily understanding
that distinction in terms of what's
being reported or withheld they should
be reporting their wages they should be
reporting their tips the employer should
be taking out deductions uh relative to
that so I don't know that this
necessarily changes any of that but
again I might be missing the point
apologies for that
foreign
it removes those two paragraphs that
allows withholdings for
tipped wages because we're no longer
having a sub minimum wage
as an employer I am not obligated or I
can
Force an employee to tell me how much
they make over an hourly rate which is
why we can't take tips made out in front
and give them to hourly employees in the
back of the house that would be a labor
violation
correct so how would you if you have a
hourly employees out front hourly
employees out back there'd be no
mechanism for tipping
because they're all hourly employees now
so there'd still be a mechanism for
tipping in this in the case of if you're
had them providing a service and
customers were leaving tips for them
they'd still be in receipt of those tips
if you're saying this is eliminating the
employer's right to pay not 725 but pay
327 this is absolutely doing that this
is making that the employer is obligated
to pay the full minimum wage instead of
paying the 327
this is changing that so if you're
talking about the loss of that
absolutely the employer is losing the
right to pay less than minimum wage and
be credited we don't necessarily call it
this way the feds call it a tip credit
uh the state doesn't refer to it as a
tip credit but yes this would be
eliminating for State purposes your
ability to uh as an employer to pay less
than minimum wage and be credited for
paying uh full minimum wage
Republic
all right
so the IRS tells us that we have to
maintain a minimum
withholding
because we're paying sub minimum wages I
don't like the word seven minimum wages
but this is what the law is
the mechanism for hourly employees that
make above minimum wage say they make 15
an hour
there is no mechanism for us to withhold
tips or to maintain a collection of
chips or anything like that to claim for
them because they're an hourly employee
they're no longer under that tipped wage
done and I'll reference it to
um you go into your doctor's office
they're allow the employees do you tip
that secretary if that secretary is
tipped how do we claim those wages how
does that employer claim those wages to
be
tips
or any other hourly employer
how do you do it now
we maintain
a
the IRS tells us we have to at least
claim wages which would be their tips up
to the minimum wage technically we're
supposed to do it to upwards of our what
we're actually claiming so they're
supposed to be reporting what they're
actually receiving in tips correct yeah
and I believe that that would be the way
it would remain today if you're saying
to me that a lot of people don't report
their tips but we're at least saying
well you should be or they we are
reporting up to minimum wage I
understand what you're saying that you
no longer would be able to just say well
I'm gonna say that it was 7.25 per hour
but in terms of how it should be done
they it should be reported what they
actually received in tips
gonna further bloody the water on that
so would that be considered unearned
income or earned income because it's
above and beyond their hourly wage if
they're receiving a tip it would be
earned income
even though they're
even though they're an hourly employee
again I believe that they presently are
an hourly employee whether this law
passes or not if someone is being
working at a restaurant or working in
any Endeavor in which they're a tipped
employee but they're being paid an
hourly wage they are both an hourly
employee and a tipped employee I would
also say that we presently do have
employees who are tipped employees who
are paid in excess of the minimum wage
of of the sub minimum rate particularly
with the workforce shortages that have
been experienced around the state there
have been many restaurants or other
environments in which tips are prevalent
where employers have elected to not
utilize the sub minimum rate because
they can't retain people in those
instances which are presently happening
whether this law passes or not my
understanding is what they're doing is
they're saying claim what you earned in
tips and they are the employer again I
don't know to your point I understand
what you're saying is that if right now
you're saying well I don't know what
they made but I'm going to at least put
it as 7.25 I guess you would have to
make some type of again estimate of what
of what they would at least be bringing
in for purposes of tips
apologies I understand I'm not
addressing the I I I I I know you can't
because it's not part of their typical
course of work
representative uh I have uh I have a few
questions I guess and the first thing
just a point
a point of order I guess is that
um
is that everybody is required no matter
who you are in the country 725 you're
required to pay that
it's the it is the uh industry the
restaurant industry that has a different
arrangement in terms of how they satisfy
that 7.25 an hour
if an employee drops below
um if they don't collect enough in tips
the employee has to make that up so that
brings the employee to 725 an hour
correct correct follow-up
so that's a starting point when you look
at the way that the restaurant industry
works is a restaurant industry has
allowed uh
to take a credit based on the amount of
tips that are received they take that
credit
and they use them the tip money against
their responsibility for the minimum
wage correct to satisfy that 7.25 an
hour yeah at the federal level they
refer to it as a tip credit and in our
level at the state level we talk about
being able to pay a sub minimum rate
so let me ask you and I I've had trouble
getting an answer to this question I've
asked a number of different people
does the employer pay
on that credit pay wages either FICA or
food of taxes on that four dollars an
hour whatever case may be to satisfy
their responsibility under the federal
do they pay taxes on that money
or is that is that kind of out there and
nobody pays any taxes on that credit I
believe they're paying on what's
reported so it's similar in line with
representative avalani was speaking to
at some level they are ultimately they
are reporting a payroll that is apparent
or supposedly inclusive of tips when I
say supposedly I'm not trying to be cute
but I do think in this industry there
are instances in which tips are
underreported
I believe that's something that happens
so to be clear I believe though what the
employer is doing is they're saying okay
this is what we believe is the you know
full uh fully reflective of remuneration
to those employees and they are paying
their withholdings or FICA whatever you
want to refer to it as they are paying
it on that number now if someone is
Under reporting if tips are being
underreported and I've got a hundred
dollars in tips but I'm saying no I got
50 or some estimate was put in and it's
less than what I actually got is FICA
being paid on the underreported portion
certainly not but on what's being
reported my understanding is the
employers are paying Fike on that but I
want to be clear in their perhaps others
in the room who are experts I'm not a
tax expert but that's my understanding
from having spoken with employers
um
I I need to close narrow this down I am
doing it out okay I'm not I'm not
criticizing
future questions going forward here we
have uh the assistant commissioner here
to talk about this amendment
again what it does so
um go ahead representative McKenzie
I'll try to narrow it down as best I can
but I have the opportunity here and I
want to ask this question
in uh in the scheme of things if we
looked at tipped employees uh under the
under the legislations before us the
tipped employee would get credit
for the under the unemployment system
for that full 7.25 an hour and they
would get they would get uh
that when they looked at uh workers
compensation they would get credit for
that 720 25 an hour correct
I can speak yeah I can speak more
specifically to uh workers comp they
would get whatever we would say what was
your average weekly wage over the
preceding period they would report that
to us and they would get that so they
would get at least the the 727 but again
when we get wage reporting or average
weekly wage earning reports on tipped
employees it is often an excess of
minimal you know they should be putting
tips in there as well
I'm sorry if that doesn't answer the
question but it doesn't answer the
question but
they would get at least 725 yes
so okay so
they're going to get 7.25 an hour
and so that's a that's a base for the
workers compensation law correct so that
pain food taxes and FICA taxes and 7.25
an hour is that the understanding of the
industry I just want to make because
it's what I
that's fine
foreign
minimum wage if they have to if the
employer has to make it up to a minimum
so if you worked at a restaurant for an
entire year
and you never made a tip
that you would make 7.25
employee would have to pay based on that
the workers competence based based on
that if that was the most you made okay
and unemployment and workers comp
because
so any other questions regarding this
amendment
any other questions on this amendment to
my left
avaloni no I'm kidding I'm teasing go
ahead go ahead I was going to go into
work no no we we got to stick we gotta
stick to this
okay
any other questions about this amendment
or the commissioner
okay thank you very much thank you now
is there any other discussion about the
amendment the with this amendment is on
the table
has been moved second discussion
a representative Schultz
and Mr chair you could do this but since
I'm the author of the amendment I just
want to be clear again
both the bill and the amendment do not
change the minimum wage
um the amendment itself
leaves in those exceptions
the carve-outs it only changes the sub
minimum wage and eliminates that
category in general it does not address
tipping it does neither does the bill
that would be on top similar to a Dunkin
Donuts worker who has an hourly rate
they make tips on top
um depending on your Dunkin Donuts if
they have one of those little collection
cups
so I just wanted to reiterate that
because I feel like we've got our
questions answered but we've also gone
into depth about what are more related
to the bill and not the amendment itself
and I just want to say my bottom line
and I started with this is if you want
to make the bill better and simplify it
regardless of your view and vote on the
bill overall
I would suggest voting for the amendment
representative kale thank you Mr chair
I'll be voting for the amendment
although I'm not quite sure whether spun
centers are included in the carve out
all right I will be supporting the
amendment not the final bill because
it's very important that we contain we
continue to have these carve outs they
were there for a reason they've been
there for a while
and I think it was an honest error on
not keeping them there and I think
that's very important regardless of
where the bill goes
so seeing no other
um
hands uh the motion on the floor is the
amendment
uh Madam Clark call the roll on
amendment number 70. Vice chair seaworth
no
rep avaloni no
no rep Prout no
rep love no
shoot
um ref bogert
no
Brett Mason no
Repco no
Drago no
ripped Granger nope
ranking member Sullivan yes
reprodi yes
rep Cahill yes RIP D Silvestro
Sy
Brett Bouchard yes rep adjectives
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
rep LeClaire
Mr chair yes
eleven two nine the amendment passes
the motion Applause is ought to pass the
amendment
does that mean the people who move the
amendment also moved to pass with
Amendment
no we'll start again you do have to you
have to make a motion okay
thank you Mr chair I move ought to pass
with amendments
that seconded
second of Bible representative Bouchard
you're um recognized to speak your
emotions I'm going to keep it brief
since it's um been discussed
but the content of the policy is this
um the sub minimum wage is a Vestige of
a situation that is irrelevant today
to be clear
moving to get rid of the sub-minimum
wage for tip workers in fact will help
um employers and employees both
I love math
I think a lot of us love math or we
wouldn't be a legislator in this
committee but not everybody's great at
it nor do they have an accountant Etc
so it's also a matter of simplicity if
folks are supposed to be making the
regular minimum wage anyway
then this make sure we do it above board
across across the way
11 states have already done this
um
this is a Vestige of Jim Crow laws and
it's beyond out of date the people who
have tipped wage jobs are overwhelmingly
women typically with children in the
home
and more importantly we've had our
incidents investigated by the U.S
Department of Labor at some restaurants
luckily not a majority
because of the confusion I wouldn't
ascribe any malice per se I think it
really is confusion
but a significant number of fines have
been paid in New Hampshire because of
this confusion I believe a fellow rep
has the exact number I could be wrong on
that but
um that's really what this the intent of
the bill is not to the other Bill dealt
with the minimum wage this is simply to
get rid of the sub minimum wage
for tipped wage workers
um which really improves the whole
system really so regular minimum wage
or higher If an employer chooses to pay
an hour hourly rate higher than that and
tips on top
thank you
[Music]
thank you Mr chair I would oppose the
otpa on this uh because this legislation
would really hurt tipped employees I
took the chance to speak to many tipped
employees I know a lot of tipped
employees I used to work in the industry
myself and uh they all universally
dislike the legislation and uh it's
obvious why if you actually think think
through the actual map of the scenario I
mean you can say that it isn't a tip ban
and no it doesn't explicitly ban tips
but the incentives are there and they'll
line up in a sense
that would uh it would make it so as an
employer it would make more sense just
to have them as a regular hourly
employee because otherwise you're losing
money right if you have an hourly
employee and they're costing you so much
then it's gonna you know you can keep
them there with and then you know just
not accept tips and then you can keep
your price down right because uh when
they're expecting a tipped employee to
earn their income and up to the minimum
wage through tips then that means that
they just they can keep their prices low
and then they can just keep the price on
the menu lower and the customers who
actually come to the business would be
better off but uh this is even though it
doesn't explicitly say this and even
though you know you can say oh you know
that it isn't a ban on tipping it's a de
facto tip ban it would result in lower
hiring rates of servers and uh even
though uh they mean well they want to
improve the amount of money that servers
are taking home uh every server I've
spoken to and every server I've ever
talked to about this sort of legislation
which is a lie universally disapprove
this the tip is
very large part of their of their
industry many people work in Food
Service specific specifically because of
the way the Tipping works and it isn't
something you want to touch lightly
for example Clerk thank you Mr chair
um
although it has been a couple years
since I worked in the industry
um I don't think personally anyway I'm
going to tip someone based on their pay
I'm going to tip someone based on their
service which again this is a service
industry
um and I kind of think for the
restaurants part
that having that Gap not having to deal
with it anymore
makes a little bit easier
um
so yeah again I I worked above minimum
wage in restaurants and
um
the restaurant always told me kind of
what I had to tip
if I had a thousand dollars of sales
they figure I'm going to make at least
15 tips I gotta claim half of that so
boom eight percent
now maybe I've made more and most of the
times I did but if that's all the
restaurant wanted to report then that's
all I reported and so the restaurant is
reporting it in into
um commissioner Adkins
you know he was talking about I think we
were talking about unemployment stuff
that wage is included in your
unemployment in what you made so
you know as long as that's being claimed
you're not just making
unemployment wages according to the 725
an hour or the minimum wage you're
making it according to your tips as well
because it's all like you said it's all
uh recordable income so thank you thank
you just uh assistant commissioner Ogden
you don't have to stay here thank you
very much for coming I know you have
other work to do for being very
courteous for coming over here and for
hanging out back there I think we're all
set you're welcome to to hang out here
and labor with us uh but if you need to
get back uh we understand
okay all right you're welcome to stay
representative uh seaworth thank you Mr
chairman
um I just want to remind my fellow
Representatives that we heard in public
testimony about the impact on the
employer there's a line in their balance
sheet that is the checks that they have
to write each week
and this law would more than double that
line
if in addition to that uh the bill that
we discussed earlier
were passed or a federal minimum wage
was raised that would more than double
that line and that's a substantial
number that's a substantial disruption
to an industry that is very important to
the state and
we shouldn't take that lightly thank you
representative Prout
thank you Mr chairman um
I believe I remember correctly that we
heard during public testimony and I'm
sure someone will correct me if I'm
misremembering that Maine did this
and then very quickly had a march on
these state house and with a effort to
repeal which they then did repeal it
um that's a very local example that hits
home for me of
if it's not good for the next date over
to the point where they had to repeal it
very quickly after passing it we should
tread very lightly before we considered
following in that
following that path of History
before I let people speak twice or
anyone else want to speak the first time
representative Schultz
I think it's great to talk about Maine
the voters of Maine eliminated the sub
minimum wage through a referendum the
legislature with heavy pressure from
um lobbyists
um
did the repeal but the people did not
representative McKenzie
uh Mr chairman I thank you
so the the concept of sub minimum wage
we've heard where it where it came from
but
in terms of every other employer in the
state of New Hampshire
every other employer who opens their
doors to work is each and every day
for the most part pay 7.25 an hour
and somehow we've created this
environment where it's acceptable for
one part of the industry
to pay sub minimum wages not only that
but to meet their obligation by taking
the the comp like taking a credit for
the tips that the employee makes
there is no other business in the state
of New Hampshire who does that
not only that but the industry also has
made other uh other Deals they they have
a reduced FICA tax
so we have a reduced minimum wage we
have a reduced FICA tax we have a
reduced food attacks and I don't know
why every other employer in the state of
New Hampshire isn't in this room saying
why not me
why are we why is this industry the only
one that's doing that and let me just
say this also I I did some research
around employees
you know they think that that it we
haven't that that they're doing they
have a a great deal
because they can work in restaurants
that are profitable restaurants but I
wouldn't say it's a 325 and not 327 an
hour uh what it is is it's a profitable
restaurant they want to be there and
they want to work there and you ask
those employees do you want to make 7.25
an hour
they would say yes but if you have to if
you frame it in a way that you want to
make 7.25 an hour and somehow you're
going to lose your tips
then they're going to say something very
different so Mr chairman this is this is
time has come to eliminate this practice
for for a segment of our economy to
bring him in line with everybody else in
the state of New Hampshire and and do
away with the sub minimum wage in the
state of New Hampshire thank you Mr
thank you
followed by representative thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to know what FICA tax
we get accredited on
if you look okay you know if you
disagree
I can show you the reference of a FICA
tax discount I'm happy to do that
if you disagree you just you'll
obviously disagree with the comments
I've never seen them okay I don't know
where they are so maybe I need a new
account no
representative colcum
I also disagree with the credit on the
FICA tax because my understanding after
listening to the commissioner was that
the employers are paying a minimum FICA
tax on 725 an hour 727 an hour and they
um are paying everything else above that
that the tipped employee is earning so
then there is no credit or deduction in
FICA tax when their minimum
responsibility is minimum wage is seven
twenty five seven twenty seven per hour
thank you
representative Clark
thank you Mr chair
um again being in the industry and
making whatever we made an hour
I've gotten checks even after working 30
hours a week for
3.75 because all my tips are included
and
um with the deductions after including
the tip income
there was nothing left in the check so
obviously I didn't work for the check I
work for the tips
thank you
representative Sullivan and then I'm
gonna
pull it up
this is not an elimination of tips
this is elimination of the sub minimum
wage
um and frankly I consider myself a
pretty good Tipper I um I used to work
for tips Once Upon a Time too and I
think most people who ever did that
make a point of
make a point of leaving good tips
um but I never ask the server are you
making sub minimum wage are you making
minimum wage are you making more than
minimum wage as you regular hourly rate
I simply give them a good 20 tip
um so this is not an elimination of tips
um I don't think anybody who goes into a
restaurant is going to think those folks
are making so much money at minimum wage
that they don't deserve a tip
um let's be real about that thank you
representative love
thank you Mr chair uh it seems like the
the one group of people that are being
left out of this is the consumer you
know the there's many families that that
have budgeted the their uh you know
their weekly uh uh going out to eat and
uh
you know if uh if the prices rise in the
restaurant
uh because of this we've heard how
they're uh their the paychecks would
would uh the the the
restaurant owners um
uh payroll will double
um
you you can't help but know that you
know the tips are going to come down uh
you know the payroll doubles the prices
of the meal goes up uh the tips come
down most most servers I know uh dread
this uh I I know plenty that they're
making two 250 you know a night for six
hours you know not a bad wage
you know the the you know they want it
left alone and uh I'll be voting right
here on this
foreign
states have already done this with no
detriment to the restaurant industry and
leaders in the restaurant industry like
The Darden companies said in an investor
call this that in the states where the
sub-minimum wage was eliminated they're
actually doing pretty well so we can
look to those States as an example and
um
from where those states have continued
to have it it has continued to be a good
thing and um
I'll leave it at that I know
representative Drago
you keep referencing the 11 states and I
guess my curiosity is when we go out to
eat in New Hampshire standard tippings
20 uh if you have good service you
probably give a little more than that
but even on the automated tipping thing
it automatically pops up at 20 now in
these 11 states that have a higher
minimum wage
is are they still receiving a 20 tip or
is it a 10 tip because
other people have mentioned that this is
going to bring down the amount of
tipping and I think that might actually
happen if you compare wages of New
Hampshire
servers compared to one of these other
11 states I'd be willing to best
probably the same we're just trying to
do it in a different way
representative Granger
thank you Mr chair another thing to
consider whenever it comes to increasing
the amount of money that come out of the
employer's pockets is that this has a
tendency to allow corporate chains to
out-compete their smaller competitors
all right I like the small I like
tandy's all right I like margaritas too
but I like tandy's because it's not a
chain right we got so many nice tiny
restaurants in New Hampshire that will
just get eaten alive by the Applebee's
and I gotta say I don't want every
restaurant to be Applebees and TGI
Fridays I want them to be the
interesting niche
creative places that we have in New
Hampshire and not just the chains
because the reason that Walmart and
Target like minimum wage increases which
this is is a minimum wage increase
basically is because they can afford it
they can take the hit they have like 40
Restaurants or 40 stores or a million
whatever they have they can they can
afford it because they know that they're
going to win out at the end of the day
when all the other stores close down
they're going to be out of business all
the other little restaurants they're
going to be under you know the mom and
pop places the little diners The Wooden
Spoon and Somersworth gone all right
they're going to be replaced by TGI
Fridays and that's what you're gonna be
stuck with
thank you
I'm going to make the final comment then
we'll have a vote
um I unfortunately I can't support the
bill
um I like the New Hampshire way
I like that an employer wants to give
7.25 to the tipped employees they can
they can give anything higher than the
the what we have now with
327 thank you four five six seven
dollars an hour
I like it that I can go to a place and I
can round up my bill to give to Veterans
I like it that if I choose to when they
have a line there that says uh if you
add one more dollar to your your bill
then that will help pay for the health
insurance of the employees I like those
options
um and um
employers have that option to do that
and more
probably will to keep the
to keep their employees one of the
things that a business owner wants is to
have happy employees
and um
I'm confident that they will make those
decisions for their businesses and for
their employees and we don't necessarily
have to mandate this
Adam clerk would you please call the
roll the uh motion on the floor is ought
to pass the amendment
Vice chair seaworth no
rep avaloni no
rep proud no
prep love no
rep bogert no
Brett Mason no rip Culkin no
prep Trigo no
rip Granger nope
ranking member Sullivan yes rep by Rudy
yes rep Cahill
yes
Deputy Silvestro yeah rep Susie
right Bouchard yes
rep agent
Brett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
replica
Mr Clerk
I mean Mr chair
no
we could trade
you know
10 to 10. right we're gonna we're gonna
take a five minute break
foreign
if everyone could um get ready to take
their seats please so we can finish our
last uh second obsession
let me guess I think we're just going to
get started with the house bill 118.
thank you
all right who are we missing out first
Mr chair we did not designate who would
write a Minority Report well I heard
reports these are all without
recommendations to these are just
reports so there isn't a yeah
all right we're going to start with our
last bill of today House Bill 118 FN and
I call on representative Granger for a
motion
uh thank you Mr chair uh I would move
that we go itl on HB 118. is there a
second
by avaloni
thank you Mr chair the reason I support
itl on this bill is I believe the
premise of the bill is flawed it is a
good idea for employers to provide basic
Union training to employees considering
the dangers inherent immune Union
unionization especially in a state that
does not have right-to-work protections
all right thank you very much it's open
for uh discussion representative
Sullivan
thanks Mr chair
I support the uh concept of this bill
um I think captive uh
meetings of employees
um
horse-feeding anti-union sentiments to
them on the job without the option of
them walking away
is simply wrong
however I am going to support the itl
because of some structural problems that
were brought to our attention with with
the way the bill has been put together
and
um therefore we'll um
we'll pack our tent and come back
another day thank you
thank you
representative attitude
thank you Mr chairman I look forward to
the second half of this year where we
can finally level the playing field
between employers and employees
regarding
um the rights to organize and labor
which is the employees right alone there
will be a second bill that comes back in
September that will address these
structural issues like representative
Sullivan mentioned uh but we are not
done with this fight
um
seeing no other hands
we have a motion on the floor uh
representative
Granger
seconded by Robert zabalani there's no
other comments if you are in favor you
will vote you say yeah if you repair the
itl you'll say yes again say no Madam
clerk please call the roll Vice chair
seeworth yes
rep avaloni yes but proud YES Prep love
yes
prep over it yes
Brett Mason yes Repco yes prep Draco yes
type Ranger yes
ranking member Sullivan yes
Preparatory yes
yes repti Silvestro yeah
rep Susie yes Brett Bouchard yes my
Badger tint
Brett McKenzie yes
the clerk votes no
replicleer yes
Mr chair yes that's 19 does one and I'm
fine with consent
me oh I'm sorry no no I apologize that's
fine I'm fine with consent
all right
um no
we're gonna say um no objection to
consent agenda nope
all right we have no other bills in
front of us at this point I'd like to
thank um representative bogert for
joining us all of you uh fresh freshmen
for uh the introduction here today and
for the uh spirited debate and the
courteous disparity debate I would
appreciate if the people who are in
subcommittees would stay behind so we
can order a schedule I am trying to have
us have one more meeting for the
remaining bills executive session and
I'd like to do it on a Thursday I will
be working with the speaker's office
tomorrow to make sure we do that
um there's a lot of things going up
there's two subcommittees and then we
have to navigate ourselves around
um we have uh call it eight bills left
um two
um and we have until the 30th of March
so I'm going to try to we're probably
not going to get any executive session
in February it's gonna be the probably
the first week of March I'm going to try
to do it on a Thursday and I will get
back to you as soon as I can if you have
a better way for me to reach you or a
better email or a better phone number
let me have it please
because I know some people don't check
some of their legislative
and I'm always writing emails to try to
update you folks on what's going on so
please personally give that after are
there any questions of the chair at this
point
yes representative Sullivan
want to compliment the chair and the way
this uh day was conducted
um I don't think there are any surprises
but there is a lot of good good will
thank you I appreciate that all right if
those eight people would stay behind and
everyone else can take off
Goodwill
yeah
I actually met with the Des this morning